But you let me know.
Oh,
cool.
And so,
yes sir.
Okay.
All right.
And then we leave it there.
I think he'd beat too nervous.
Yeah,
like you said,
boom.
And we're alive.
You FC motherfucker.
Bad away.
Champion,
Tj Dillashaw and Duane Ludwig masters splinter.
What's up buddy?
Good to see you man.
You got golf shirts now to look at you.
You respectable motherfucker.
I'm 40 now.
Oh my game.
People walked in and I know Dojo.
He's got to look dressed to the nines.
You know,
looking like it's a the job.
But there's a warning sign on the wall.
Says explicit language.
Oh,
so you,
you let people know people are going to be swearing up in this bitch.
Yes sir.
Line up motherfuckers.
Dot.
On the map first though.
Let see that when you teach classes,
do you swear I'm passionate?
Yeah.
No you are or you get fired up.
That's why I don't teach the kids,
the kids classes that coach that.
So you have a children's program?
Yes sir.
Nice Dude.
I love the fact that you take regular classes.
I've watched you on the Instagram bantamweight champion of the world.
Oh yeah.
Regular regular classes with regular people.
See they've been there with you like Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Starstruck and weirded out go mandrills I love it.
I love,
I mean obviously none of his classes or regular though.
You know what?
Even if you're an average Joe coming up the street,
like Duane is teaching you the same shit that I'm doing,
you know?
But yeah,
working out with a guy that's never had a real fight before.
You know what I mean?
He'll always remember that,
you know,
always get to work out with me.
So it's,
it's uh,
it's cool,
man.
I liked doing it and especially at Dwayne's Jim,
to kind of shows like the true love that I have for the system and being in
there.
Yeah.
I mean,
what kind of fucking sport other than MMA is that even possible?
Could point,
right?
It was control Jujitsu.
You could do that,
but the people do.
Most people don't know who the Jujitsu guys arm and you're fighting on fucking
television all the time and it's almost,
it's almost too easy to have that happen in this sport.
Now.
There's people you should be,
you shouldn't be spot on with it.
It happens,
you know,
that's why a controlled environments also awesome.
That's why like did I feel like the small kind of training camps and teams that
have been so beneficial because you knew exactly who you're working out with.
Who are we getting better with?
But there are times to work out with the average guys,
you know,
not when I'm getting ready for a fight or don't want to get hurt,
kind of thing.
And then his is a very controlled system when we're doing Dutch.
Trills did,
uh,
it,
it's uh,
you're not going to go crazy,
you know,
there's so many different approaches to training fighters.
Yes sir.
And you obviously have hit,
would you guys have like the best fighter trainer relationship that I know
about?
Cause you guys are so tight.
It's like you guys are really a team.
Whereas there's always some weird animosity with fighters and trainers and the,
the blowups or just like Ben and women,
like when,
when men and women break it up and you fucking bitch,
you fucking,
you fucking fuck you.
Oh yeah,
that happens with,
that makes me so sad when I see like fighter trainer blowouts when they separate
and talk shit about each other like God,
that's,
so,
that's such a bummer.
I think it's both of them having too big of an ego.
One must be like the coach may be coaching the fighter wants to be more popular
or whatever it may be,
you know?
Um,
and it just the,
I don't know,
whenever,
whenever Dwayne came into the gym and as soon as he was there from the first
practice,
I knew we were going to get along.
He's a crazy motherfucker.
He likes to go hard.
I'm competitive and as kind of like everything I do.
You know what,
you're also,
you have a very,
very well thought out system.
Like I've been,
I was very impressed with like just your documentation of your system,
how you have all these different things worked.
At least these aren't like just happy.
I mean there's obviously creative creativity involved when an actual fight is
happening,
but your system is so well thought out.
And so
Bruh,
hence Iv,
I feel that's,
that's where I'm supposed to be doing is organizing the chaos of a fight so that
the regular person can understand what's happening.
When all was fighting and training,
fighting was scary and I was very scared of it.
So I want to make sure I understood what was going on.
So I just started mapping it out and a lot of that came from Cynthia Rutan
because he had the number system of three was jab,
cross hook rather than three just been the left hook.
So he sparked the initial interest to just start categorizing everything,
put things into a system and it helped out.
He talks about it nonstop.
He doesn't sleep.
He's only one way to begin,
get a text message in the middle of the night.
We're coming up to a fight and like it'd be like 12 one o'clock and it's even if
he's in Colorado,
it's two o'clock for him.
And uh,
getting a random text message or what I should be doing for this fight or what
don't you like me?
He's watching sparring tapes of what I was doing.
When you change this and change that.
I mean this guy cares about our career just as much as I do and that's why it
works.
You know,
I want him,
I want him to be some changes coming.
It's,
it's a great thought out system but it like I've never had the same training
camp and I don't ever have the same column when we have like your system base is
the same but it always veers off.
Like I don't even know what the Tj combos anymore.
I think it's changed that changed things like eight times and so it's always
like an add on or change.
So yeah.
Well I remember the first time you fought hand and morale when you won the title
and Dwayne and I had lunch together and it was a bunch of people at the table,
but Duane didn't even know they were alive.
He wasn't even paying attention,
who's just telling me exactly how it was going to go down.
And he was just talking about all the things a bit in his hands are moving and
shoulders are twitching,
is move it around back and forth.
And he was going a hundred miles an hour with his voice.
It's bottled water,
blah,
blah.
I was like,
wow,
dude,
you're geared up.
And he goes,
he's gonna fuck him up.
He's going to fuck with that for sure.
I mean,
you see the emotion that he shows inside doctor on an African fights,
you know,
so,
uh,
that's how much he cares going into.
That's on nervous.
He is,
you know.
Um,
and like I said,
if you have a coach that cares that much about you and your career,
then you don't let it go.
Yeah.
When you were,
when you were in Sacramento and then you move to Colorado,
you have basically kind of had to start from scratch.
A lot of people obviously know who you are.
You are well sought out a trainer,
but you were opening up your own place from scratch and now that place is
fucking mobbed and you're expanding.
Yeah.
Yes sir.
Yeah,
we're expanding and uh,
just continuing to grow and have a good positive outlet for people to explore
their soul.
Right.
Uh,
that's why I'm here is to teach martial arts.
So it's a,
I'm glad everyone else's is realizing that as well.
And I can cross paths with the,
and then just like Tj Dillashaw and helped them become better martial artists.
And it's just the good,
um,
you know,
100% living,
living,
living vicariously through te Jane on my athletes and everybody under the BMT
umbrella.
And it's a good way to give back and basically relive and other career for the
most part.
Right.
So,
and that's what we should be doing anyways,
paying the positive lessons forward and onto the next generation.
And that's,
uh,
that's the definition of Sensei actually,
meaning history teacher,
teacher,
you know,
from those who've come before you.
So,
and to have somebody like Tj is dedicated as he is,
it's,
it's a true blessing.
And uh,
that's why I'm all in.
He's all in.
I'm all in,
let's go.
Yeah.
Well it's just rare that you find all in coach and all in fighter and they get
together and you guys have such unique working.
I'm,
well,
I'm more than all in the same with you.
And I'm going to dictate,
you know,
like,
like if I'm not completely like full blown into it,
I mentally am fucked when I get home.
You know,
y'all coming off of this second victory over Cody and then being able to stop
him even quicker this time and the,
and just all the crazy shit talking that led up to that fight and the results of
the first fight.
I mean that's got to be very satisfying to you that everything is going
according to plan.
Absolutely man.
Um,
it is,
especially with the whole build up,
you know,
it was like two years of just bullshit having to deal with that man.
That's not the kind of person I am.
You know,
I'd really be in the mountains that you not be able to get ahold of me hunting
or just camping and like if I,
if I could disappear,
I take advantage to do it,
you know,
so that crazy attention and just like the shit talk and the TV show them
accusing me of everything.
Like,
you know,
that took a lot,
you know?
And so for all that to be like taken off my shoulders,
it feels great for you though.
There's God that's gotta be a real feeling of like retribution to look.
No matter what they said,
you had the right idea,
they might not have been happy that you decided to do it for yourself.
And the right move for yourself was to go and go to Colorado and be with Dwayne.
But obviously you were right.
Yeah.
Oh,
100% I was right.
I mean that's why I made the decision.
I'm definitely,
and you've got to be selfish in this,
this sport.
He got to do what's best for yourself.
And some ways without fucking people over,
you have to be self.
Of course,
we got to know what's best for you.
And so the ultimate decision for me was when I got an ultimatum,
you know,
like Uriah knew how much I like training with Duane.
He knew how great it was for my mentality and we just vibed right away,
you know?
And they didn't.
And so when he gave me the ultimatum like,
look man,
you're there doing your camper,
Dwayne are doing with us.
I was like,
well then you don't have my best interests in heart.
I'm Outta here.
You know,
like I sold my house,
bought when I moved out to Colorado,
like I dropped everything and went yeah,
that was tough and I was a tough situation to go through and uh,
I,
yeah,
I made the right choice.
Well,
your,
your decision and the way you approached it was very similar to what you were
doing too.
Because when I talked to you,
you're like,
I'm gonna open up my own gym and Colorado.
And I remember thinking whenever someone thinks they're going to start from
scratch with a new gym by themselves,
I'm like,
Ooh.
I mean,
I wish you well,
but damn,
that's a lot of work,
you know,
as well as anybody.
Yes sir.
I've,
I've known since I was a kid,
I was going to be a world champion and have my own academy and Colorado check,
check
darting a gym is tough,
man.
We're,
we're doing it now while we're,
we've going through it for the last year,
year and a half down here in southern California.
So the new places called,
uh,
the training lab,
the training lab is spelled funny.
It's got where Eui and rain,
cause Mark Munoz had rain down in lake forest and Sam Kalvia,
the guy that I moved down for,
for her strength conditioning and just his,
his crazy mind,
he's beyond smart,
like heal everything he talks about,
like I have to be at his house for hours,
pretty much doing a podcast with him to figure out what he's talking about.
And usually always goes over your head.
You know,
I've gone,
like I said,
I'm always full blown.
I made 100%.
And so as soon as he started showing me the science behind what my body needs to
do,
if it were from my diet,
my recovery,
um,
the days I'm working out,
my,
the way I'm doing my strength conditioning and what if I'm going to go bigger or
how far I am from camp.
Like everything has a rhyme and reason.
Like every calorie I eat,
every macronutrients I eat.
He's got it down and written down.
He's like,
this guy stays up late and works in and he doesn't do it for the money or the
pride.
Like he doesn't want anything.
Like we do it out of his garage.
You know,
it's like an old rocky style training with Drago Science.
I saw that on the UFC countdown videos,
man out in the park.
You know,
we're doing crazy.
Yesterday I was out in the park with them doing a bunch of crazy stuff and a lot
of reaction time stuff.
And uh,
just the way he trains his very,
very scientific.
And I've seen the gains insanely for as old as I am.
I'm the strongest and fastest I've ever been told,
you know,
32 and I've been trained since I was eight.
You know,
I never got into diet,
never got an Indian of this until I started picking Sam's brain.
And,
uh,
I think the real,
I mean,
everything's,
it's not bro science either.
We're not like,
oh,
I think I feel better.
I'm testing myself,
you know,
I've,
I boosted my hormones.
I wasn't able to get my wife pregnant for three years.
And it happened in three months after meeting Sam.
Like I went full blown.
I went so full blown that I created my own like spice company around his diet.
You know,
like,
I don't see,
well,
what does he got you doing differently?
How were you eating before and what were you doing before for strength and
conditioning before you met him?
Um,
so it was,
I didn't care about what I eat.
I was,
I don't cut much weight,
you know,
three fives isn't a very big cut for me.
So you walk around it,
I'm like right now private,
a couple one 50 this morning.
Um,
that's a little bit lighter than normal.
I haven't been to my,
I have to,
I bulk up to go 35.
I put on another like good five pounds of muscle before I start to even worry
about my weight at 35.
Um,
but I was just eating whatever,
you know.
Um,
and I used to make fun to Danny for being gluten free.
If like gimme more gluten,
I don't care.
I'll eat whatever I want.
And the best,
you know,
I'll just train hard,
train hard and everyone,
but,
uh,
not only my age but just the learning the science behind it.
And I'm not eating grains,
you know,
no sugars unless it's a simple as like a from fruits and stuff like that.
Um,
yeah man.
I mean it,
it's,
it's a special diet.
I'd say like the clue you like almost go like Paleo Keto Kinda.
But obviously our bodies can't do that because I need the simple cards and you
carbs are run off and stuff.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean he's really,
I don't want to give away all the secrets,
but yeah,
man,
he's,
he's changed up a lot with me.
If you don't want to give away all our secrets,
but when it comes to nutrition,
like what is,
what is different,
what kind of protein easy have you eating?
What portions of protein,
how
much of it is fat?
Well,
you're getting your fat from avocado,
coconut oil.
What do you get it from?
Oh yeah,
a lot.
A lot of,
and not another,
it's not a coconut oils.
Um,
uh,
they even pre make my meals,
so I don't really,
I don't even think about what meals I'm meeting Jesus Christ.
It has all three of my meals and two of my snacks every day.
And you just,
you live in that area when you're in training camp?
Yes.
Yeah.
So I just bought a house in Yorba Linda area.
I love it.
It's amazing.
It's a real good family area,
good school district.
So,
um,
that's how you know,
your life has changed when you're looking at houses for school districts.
Trust being a,
being a father's gaze,
lucky change the whole shifting of your world.
It's everything.
Yeah.
I mean it's everything.
That's all you think about,
you know,
it takes a while to be realized.
You were a different person.
Like,
oh,
I'm a different person than I used to be.
I remember you made a comment before saying that those,
uh,
an old banana or a freshman or something was a bit from my act.
Is that what it was?
That's when I realized some of that,
there was two bananas and one of them was like yellow and perfect.
And the other one was brown and fucked up.
But my daughter loves bananas.
So I took that Brown fucked up banana and I ate it because I realized that I
was,
I was putting her above me and that that was,
I never thought about that before.
And then I said because I love my wife,
she's an awesome person but if it's just me and her,
that bitch is getting a shitty banana.
That's what I tried to Frickin Subaru car cause it's got five star crash rating
and good in the snow.
Yeah.
I think of the kids first.
Subaru,
Dave own Denver,
Colorado,
Colorado.
Get a Tesla.
Oh supporting the podcast guys drop 50 grand.
You know you,
you go on the website,
you punch the information,
you put in $1,000 deposit and then you got to wait for a while for it to be
built.
So it's not like I dropped 50 grand,
ended up going to lease it to the business anyway.
But I've been wanting to get one for awhile.
It's funny men how Subarus,
like they've proven themselves in Colorado just for reliability.
Awesome.
Yup.
There,
you know,
ton of old ones still floating around everywhere.
Literally,
if you go through boulder,
it's like 50% Subarus.
I would say that.
Yeah.
They just,
they've just said,
let's just cut the shit.
Yes.
One is the best in snow.
Let's stop fucking around.
They never break fucking Japanese cars made.
They never,
I've had three Lexuses.
Never had a single problem with any of them.
That's good.
They'll for like 1520 years I've had Alexis's they never fuck up perfect.
They just start,
or every time no fuck ups.
300,000 miles on it.
It's still going to run.
Yeah.
Other cards you get in the windows rolled halfway down.
What the fuck's going on?
Dang.
Lights go off of the dashboard.
What is this?
Put black tape over it.
You want to see it in a more,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Well,
you know,
I dunno.
It's gotta be difficult to build cars.
Speaking of cars do,
does everybody know you have that fucking thing outside of you look at a lot of
talk about,
Oh yeah,
I'm going to talk about it.
Yeah.
You got one of my favorite cars ever.
NSX.
It's amazing car things.
A space ship.
It really is man.
Real space ship.
It's a real fun car,
doesn't it?
What are we talking about?
It has four engines.
Three of them are electric.
I mean,
it is a crazy,
at that tree,
Turbo v six I mean it's only got a high five hundreds and horsepower.
Look at that fun,
but it high 500 Corecon is insane because it's,
uh,
it's a,
two electric motors,
so I have to start,
it's so fast to zero to 60 in 2.9 seconds.
That's fast,
dude.
So good looking too.
I love the way they look.
They look like a car that's supposed to be built in 2018 you know what I mean?
It's like that Shit's from the future.
It took them a long time to create that car and when they stopped making the,
the second generation of sex,
like what,
2005 I had one.
Oh,
did you?
Yeah,
that's why to,
yeah.
Yeah.
I had one in the early nineties and then I had one in 2003.
Okay.
Yeah,
we'll,
we'll uh,
did you like the early 90?
[inaudible] I like the headlights better than the newer one.
Okay.
But they're all awesome.
Yeah.
They're just,
it's not a fast car.
Like if you buy it,
I think in a 270 horsepower.
Okay.
But it's all aluminum.
It's mid engine.
It sounds amazing when it gets high,
like hot in the high revs,
but it doesn't sound like,
it's not like a,
like an old Mustang.
It's like full like metal.
Is it driving the street?
It's like a sophisticated sound,
but a cool sound.
The vtech engine,
that was my one problem with the new NSX was how quiet it was cause it's a
hybrid.
So I'm like,
like I said,
it was a one of three cars in the United States right now that have a custom
exhaust forward and make it sound a lot better.
This guy on Chicago a be rogue,
I think it is,
um,
has designed a,
uh,
an exhaust for it.
You know,
that car is also,
even though it's an accurate,
their car is made in design in the United States.
Yeah.
The factories in Ohio,
right?
Yeah.
It's a total American car under the accurate.
What is American anymore?
I mean I don't,
I don't even understand this.
How we order stuff.
It's always from China or Pakistan or something so,
but it's also like the parks like are all the parts made here?
Everything you know like assembled.
That's an issue with Harley Davidson,
right?
Trump wants us to ban Harley Davidson's now.
I didn't boycott boycott Holly Davidson.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause Harley Davidson is going to shift their factories to somewhere to make
some part of it or maybe all of it.
We talk about the Elon Musk and saving the world.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't think anybody could do Trump's job.
I don't think anybody could be president.
I think it's stupid.
There's no way to ask one person to have that much responsibility.
Yes.
That person in these big 10 15 people to handle that job for sure.
Maybe 30 there's no way I'd ever want the pressure of that.
That job.
Fuck that.
How much he's actually doing though.
I don't want it.
How much pussies getting?
I really want to know cause I don't think he's just stopped getting pussy.
He's like Trump for sure.
You know on the roll there's gotta be,
I mean what the him and Melania is still hook up and she seems upset with them.
It's interesting as a drama has watched it all go down like cause his date
investigation closing in on them or they're going to put them in jail or is he
going to be like fuck you,
I'm getting my special flying away.
Sure he has a spaceship.
Well if he does and he's trying to find out if he can get one on the gold one
that says Trump on this quick bailed on him when they got out of the Paris
accord.
Yeah,
the climate accord.
I don't,
yeah,
I don't know enough about this.
I don't know how your brain holds on even that much information.
Either member.
Everything I remember too much.
It's a problem.
I don't remember shit.
But like my wife will tell me from Tuesday,
my wife,
he told me that she's like,
we're standing right here.
She'll like go over all the details cause she remembers all of it.
I'm like,
okay,
I guess you're right.
We'll get it off.
But I'll tell you in 1852 exactly.
Exactly.
Awesome facts and stats,
some stupid stats when it comes to martial arts.
I feel like I understand have a good grasp on what's happening.
But the outside of martial arts,
I don't know that much.
Yeah.
But that's probably good man.
You know,
I think there's something there.
There's some real power in that.
Having a singular focus.
I think in order to be great at something,
you have to be that way.
I wouldn't be spread dealer,
but I would say very dominantly focused.
I think you're right because I would,
if I was only thinking about MMA,
I would not be here.
Good point.
Right?
Like you need some other things that interest you to relieve the pressure have
to,
otherwise it's too much and you snap.
What is the best one for you?
They escape wise.
Yeah.
Uh,
jumping on my Malibu boat and my backyard and Colorado and wake surfing or
hunting,
both those I getting out.
I just went and hiked around in the mountains of Colorado for,
I only got to do two and a half day cause I'm too busy.
But by myself,
no one else.
First time ever Hyundai area.
I scouted it like three days before camp,
but just went out by myself.
Could,
didn't have a cell phone reception,
nothing.
Just to your own thoughts for two and a half days.
So this type of year,
this time of year,
our tree mule deer,
was that what it was?
Yeah.
So I tried to get an elk tag in Colorado,
but I didn't draw,
I did draw a meal,
deer tag for the same area.
Um,
but it,
it's so it's heavily dominated elk,
so it's hard.
He and mule deer there.
Yeah.
It's hard to get those two to coincide with each other,
but that's,
that's hard hunting.
That's what mountain hunting.
That's the real deal.
Yeah,
man.
I mean you're going from 8,000 to 10,
11,
12,000 feet,
you know,
hike two or three of those mountains and your toes when you get back.
Hey Man,
when you do that,
bring that.
I'm shroom tech sport.
Um,
on a trim tech sport,
any cordyceps mushroom supplement,
anything along those lines.
That's literally how it came about.
They realize these high altitude,
uh,
cattle herders were realizing that their cows were more active when they were
eating these certain mushrooms.
And that's a quarter subs mushroom.
We actually grow,
we don't grow,
but you know,
we,
the company buys it from some growers to grow it off caterpillars.
Oh,
no way.
They're going off the caterpillar.
It's fucking weird shit,
man.
All quarter set mushrooms are grown that way.
I don't know about all,
but a lot of them.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
They grow them on caterpillars,
so they're definitely not vegan.
You know what I mean?
I take shroom tech.
Is that a plant based?
Like it's fungal based.
Okay.
Mushroom done mushrooms.
They take in air and they breathe out carbon dioxide like we do.
They're closer to the animals in the art to plants.
This is a whole different cat you've ever listened to.
Paul Stamets.
Oh my God,
I did a podcast with him.
Strap yourself in,
take three hits,
hold on tight,
buckled down and listen to that guy's podcast.
He's a real mycologist.
I had an actual scientist who studies mushrooms and he's amazing.
So that's how cordyceps mushrooms are grown.
Okay.
Where's the caterpillar underneath that?
You can just buy it as a culture.
Oh,
that's a culture of them.
Thought it would have a caterpillar in there.
Oh,
okay.
So this is uh,
for your,
for your home you could,
that's probably even better,
right?
Get it fresh.
I don't know how to make it either.
A lot of dudes,
gross rooms,
so it's pretty easy apparently,
but just it's a phenomenal supplement and if you're doing anything high
altitude,
he will absolutely increase your endurance.
That is one of the only supplements that I'll tell people.
Look,
if you're skeptical about any of this shit,
please,
I want you to,
before you work out an hour before you take four shroom tech sports and get
ready because you're going to have an extra gear.
You got one extra gear and training.
It's like one Bush.
I take it before every session.
With Tj,
it's from tech and Alpha brain.
It's a 12,
it's cordyceps,
mushrooms,
B12 and adaptogens.
And those are all really important things for energy.
So it was,
does California have you do an all kinds of supplementation and what does he got
you a taking?
So everyone's got a different supplement plan because he does a hair analysis
from us and decided Jesus Christ is assign.
He,
oh he really,
everything's got numbers man.
Every they are now.
So yeah.
So my supplement based would be different than Dwayne's.
I mean a lot of us have that we have at the same Aminos,
we have the same is creatine obviously depending on where you're going for
fight.
Um,
you know,
that kind of stuff.
But when it comes down to what's in your body mineral wise,
like I might have more magnesium,
more and more this and more that it gets her body back to homeostasis.
So we'll take out.
We have too much of,
I might need more vitamin B.
Be examples like things you didn't,
you have too much of.
I have.
Well I have too much arsenic in my body.
Oh,
what were you eating?
Um,
I think it's rice.
I think the rice has given a lot of,
because rice is heavily because it's grown in water and so the arsenic,
yeah.
Yeah.
So I think it's the right,
it could be from my tattoos as well.
I mean tattoo.
Yeah,
the ink has arsenic in it.
I'm fucked.
Yeah,
man.
The only person that have more arsenic in my body than me in our camp was a cub
Swanson.
Wow.
And he's all covered his whole back and stuff.
Yeah.
Dad is crazy.
Now.
Did,
what?
Did they find a way to eliminate it?
Can you eliminate it?
Yeah,
so I'm taking a while.
I'm taking a lot of different stuff for it,
but I'm taking chlorella.
I juice everyday.
I juice Cilantro.
So launches are good for heavy metals.
Getting a detox.
Um,
I'm taking methionine,
which is like Amino to pull it out of your body.
And then he's got drops.
I'm on that.
Don't even know what they are now.
Have you got a second test?
And it's come down by over 50% oh wow.
Yeah,
I had.
Oh.
So if it's still in your system and it's not,
you're not eating rice anymore,
so it's gotta be from your tattoos?
Yeah,
it could be.
I mean,
or is it just slowly take,
you can't so you can do a correlation where they do it by ivy,
but that stuff's like,
it's hard.
It's hard on y'all,
how fast it comes out.
So it comes out in like pimples.
It'll come out.
Like when I'm on it,
it started coming out of my arm.
Like it would mainly I'd get pimples throughout my arm and that's kind of your
body pushing it.
You also push it out through your urine and things like that,
but it'll come out of your skin.
Arsenic exit son.
Yeah.
I've tested for arsenic wants cause,
but I was eating sardines.
I was eating a lot of sardines and apparently they,
they live around the bottom of the ocean and they kept a lot of the heavy metal
poisonings from that way.
That's crazy.
But it makes sense with Rice.
That totally makes sense.
Yeah.
But everyone's got different supplements like a,
it just depends on what's in your body.
Like how,
like,
what you need to get back to perfect homeostasis,
right.
And then he adds like,
you know,
the certain Amino body or muscle building and,
and um,
ubiquinol and the Krill oils and things like that for um,
building red,
new red blood cells and things like that.
What does his scientific background?
So I don't know all of that.
I know he worked for NASA.
Um,
he was,
um,
like working with the nuclear anti [inaudible] defense system and then he missed
a Christmas or something and decided to,
uh,
move home and be a school teacher and you became a calculus teacher.
Whoa.
Um,
and he has like a private high school and uh,
people would travel over the world to do,
is clap to take his class.
He wants him a war to be in the best calculus teacher in the world.
Like all of his kids on his placement test score.
I don't know if it's perfect or very high.
And it was so,
yeah,
he's,
he's just a like,
math,
math will tell you everything that you,
and the numbers,
it's not,
like I said,
it's not bro Science.
It's to the exact,
you know,
exactly for getting better.
Um,
yeah.
Well he must apply that science to his understanding of,
of energy and of,
of intensity because like the way you guys train,
it's very intense,
very explosive.
It reminds me a lot of what I'm seeing at least have like Marvin Marinovich his
type training,
like a lot of plyometrics,
a lot of things along those lines.
Would that be fair to say?
Absolutely.
But then we also do,
we're also doing,
um,
a dead lifts and cleans and we're doing a lot of stuff,
man.
Um,
and he mixes it up a lot.
Yeah.
Depending where you're at in your camp,
um,
how your body also the recovery.
So the recovery is huge.
He listens to our,
our,
uh,
our body while we're sleeping.
So he gets a report every morning of how is next to you in the bed?
Pretty much like if you had a couple of glasses of wine,
you know,
like why you're not recovering.
He just like knows our,
if you notice you're too stressed out.
He knows.
Like he'll tell me when I'm going to get sick.
Like he's caught onto me getting sick before I got sick.
It was like,
oh,
your body's about to crash.
Like you need to like take the next day,
next two days off,
like really rest.
I mean,
he helped keep TJ in that last fight.
Help repair some injuries.
Right.
We have to talk
about him,
but he,
he keep it without Sam.
Yeah.
That fight may have been different.
Probably my last two fights.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you're right.
Yes sir.
I'm in dealing with some serious stuff,
the last couple of fights,
but I've been able to keep my body very,
very strong.
You also spend some time with doctor Neil Riordan down in Panama and did that,
was that for the same type of injury?
Same thing.
Yeah.
So a combination combination of the science of stem cell and Dr. Neal Roden as
well as Maura here.
I got,
I mean,
I got stem cells in the states.
I got an in Panama,
like I've had to do a lot to hold myself together kind of thing,
you know,
and I feel great.
Um,
because of the way I'm training and,
and uh,
yeah,
I don't think people understand the,
the kind of strain on your body of fight camp puts.
It's fucking crazy mean.
If I worked out the way you guys did once,
I'm wreck for a week,
but that's what I was doing two a days every day.
Constantly going at it.
And then there's ice baths.
Is Sam,
what does he have you doing?
Sauna,
ice bath was you,
have you got,
um,
for our recovery,
I mean mainly it's just a lot of,
most of I'm taking the time off,
but we have,
um,
it's always changing.
It's always evolving too.
He's got like this,
I'm all pro,
we do for like some sort of stem on her muscles where I do light.
They're like electrical stim.
I do,
I do a light therapy.
Um,
there's this new place he's starting to work with,
uh,
down in mission Viejo called like Otu recovery center where we'll do,
we'll do Cryo,
we'll do hyperbaric chamber,
we'll do,
um,
was it [inaudible] vac or something like that.
A bunch of different stuff we're going to add to is a machine we were talking
about really recently where it jacks you up in all in altitude and that brings
you down and like changes the pressure inside that little tube and that's
supposed to be pretty amazing.
Did you have good results with that?
I actually haven't done it yet.
So then he's telling me now that like we're going to add this now.
Like it's always like every time I come back to camp it's like we're adding in
the next step.
He doesn't do it all at once as it should always changing the evolvement at the
time.
He'd be like,
you teaching me the BMT black belt system right away without knowing any of it,
you know?
So he like gets my body
slowly adapted to certain things,
then he adds to it.
What about massage?
Yeah.
What kind of massage?
He doesn't have me do it.
I just do it because I love it,
you know?
But,
uh,
I,
I always do deep tissue for the most part.
And then I'm a lot of that like Matt,
like the stretching.
Um,
kind of like a Thai massage type stuff.
A lot of time massage and then the also,
yeah,
exactly.
I forgot.
They'd stretch.
Amazing.
Standing your back and
your arms up.
You're like,
I have a student,
Thomas see me.
He is by far the best massage therapist I've ever come across.
He's really,
he's bad ass.
There's ones out there,
man.
He,
he,
he's,
he's got a black belt in massage therapy,
that's for sure.
Like a,
a good massage.
Shouldn't
feel that great to the average person.
Like it's going to hurt to hurt.
It's how you're going to feel afterwards.
And I actually now I've learned to enjoy the pain kind of thing.
Well yeah,
actually.
So I'm an,
I've been working this whole last camp to a guy that really helped me get to my
camp was um,
how many do it right now?
Drawing a blank.
But uh,
Javier,
he uh,
did a lot of work on me.
Um,
hold me in place as well to body bodywork as opposed to like,
what's like,
what does body work as opposed to regular massage?
So He's more of like,
um,
the nerve,
like the nervous system of all your,
your pathways.
Um,
and really find out what's weak.
I can't,
he'll tell me like something that's like week before I even let him know before
the massage.
Can they,
how can tell that?
I don't know how I can tell that.
I'm not really sure.
I'd have to have him tell you.
There's something weird about people that touch people's bodies all the time and
you go,
this is all horse shit.
And then they put their arm or shoulder,
what's going on with your shoulder?
You're like,
what do you mean?
And like,
it's very a very tense up here.
You have an injury,
you nursing like,
well how'd you know six sentence?
For sure.
It's,
they just get used to like the difference between your left side and your right
side.
I like,
oh,
something's going on here.
They just,
it's like everything else,
right?
Like your understanding of what an athlete's is capable of is so different than
a person who doesn't train just,
and I think it's gotta be,
you know,
we don't,
we can't imagine someone would be able to touch your pack and go,
Oh,
you've got a tear.
You got them,
you got a muscle tear.
You're like,
what?
But there's also this massage therapist,
they'll do something like,
how's it feel?
You feel better?
It's like,
Oh yeah,
I guess I feel better now,
but this guy will find my weaknesses without me even telling him he'll know like
things that I need to get worked on.
Uh,
he knows my hips are lined up,
like kind of like almost like a chiropractor as well,
but he doesn't do chiropractic work.
Good.
Yeah.
Would it be like how practice?
I just don't think it's real.
I love him.
I love to get lined back up.
Good.
I've had neck,
my neck just tweaked and not be able to do anything and then get lined back up
and be ready to go.
It's definitely how size I think works better than anything.
But it just too much about what,
what chiropractic medicine was,
how it started.
It started by a guy who was a magnetic healer who learned about it in a seance
and then his son murdered him and took over the business,
turned out to be something good but they didn't.
People are crazy.
Yes.
The good thing about it,
I mean it's interesting what's good and what's not.
You know what's provable is,
it's very interesting.
What's,
they just,
they,
people always say that it's a part of the National Institute of health care.
Is that what it is?
Uh,
a part of their recommended program,
but it's not anymore.
They were,
they removed it.
There's not,
there's no real evidence that shows it works.
The thing about it is though,
it's like I just adjusted myself.
Like I adjusted my knuckles.
That's literally what they're doing,
what they're doing to your back.
I've had for whatever of it,
you know,
over a hundred fights and whenever and how my neck jacked up wrestling and shots
and I've had pretty significant injury where I couldn't like change lanes and
turn and drive and then go get adjusted.
And be back to square one I think has done the same thing with massage.
I think there's something to people touching you and working on stuff and Lou
and loosening you up in a way that you can't do.
And I'm not saying that there's not good chiropractors out there that really
understand all the other things like cold laser therapy and different kinds of
manipulation in terms of like,
you know,
muscle stretching and um,
um,
what does that type of a rolfing,
rolfing is legit.
It's that massage,
just a brutal,
brutal massage.
But it's one of those things where it breaks everything down and then after it's
over,
everything's very loose.
Okay.
And there's,
there's a lot of chiropractors that are really good physical therapist too,
but just the,
the underlying principles of what the chiropractic medical practice is,
it started off with nonsense.
The guy thought he could fix everything by adjusting you.
Oh,
for some reason your eyesight let me fix it.
Got past the limits.
We fix it.
I'm gonna crack your neck and you're not going to have bad breath anymore,
like stupid.
But if he tells you to believe that people are like,
oh,
nice power,
belief to serious.
Yeah,
that's part of the problem is that it's one of the things they prey on.
One of the things that they use is an not necessarily theirs.
There's levels to this whole,
you know thing.
It's not just regular chiropractor sessions.
There's,
you know,
there's different kinds of air quote healers that have like different systems.
If they think they can push down the middle of your back and cure your pancreas.
So much horseshit,
but it's not real.
You know what the,
but there are a bunch of things you can do that are real and massage is one of
them.
Massage is this.
It's absolutely a fact that it's helped loosen people up and relax people and
just something about being manipulated like that.
Like if somebody really digging their elbow into your tissue and loosen it and
everything up.
We got this fucking Tim Tam.
You ever used one of these?
Yeah,
I have a,
I have a Tim Tam and I have a third gun.
His work to this is the mother.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah,
I think I have that thing is the shit that thing's amazing.
Oh yeah.
Frost.
A hobby in the house.
Anything that's like knotted up and really bother.
You get hammered with that fucking thing.
And then afterwards it's like,
what am I?
Students made one of those that have a little a drill or a
tennis ball or something on it.
Like wow,
this is,
I mean it's just the same kind of motive.
It's going to make this thing for $30
fuck a playground.
So when you guys are doing camp,
do you move down to California for the what you do six or eight weeks?
How many weeks are you doing?
I do a lot.
I've got to do more than I probably should,
but I mean I'd almost do can't before I get into camp kind of thing.
I like to get yourself in shape.
Yeah,
I like to be in shape when camp starts,
you know,
it's always developing new things.
This camp,
Dwayne came out,
like started coming out in nine weeks before the fight.
Maybe 10 my pain,
it was a lecture more than two months and he would do a three days.
He'd come out flout Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday or no,
I'm sorry.
Uh,
Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday.
So I'll be out here three days back home,
four days.
Splitting time.
But it worked at y.
With that I was able to find a,
which I was already aware of.
I slowed down.
What the fuck?
Sorry.
I get excited when I got my note pad right here folks.
I want tell you I'm sorry I got to talk slower today.
We'll talk slower.
People was complain.
I talk too fast.
I'm going to talk slower.
But you get a lot of information in and that one minute in the corner.
That's what I talked about cause that's why I talk fast.
Yeah.
This is why I'm wired.
Why I talk fast.
I got about 30 seconds to talk and really information,
which is also why I have the actual system and all the,
the,
the draws a combination so I can condense it.
Right.
I don't want to say jab,
cross,
Hook,
cross three and that came from box right in the corner for my IC tomorrow fight,
tell me what to do.
And I walk out there in 30 seconds later I'd knock them out,
whatever it is.
You know,
like you guys able to get the information off and there's a system to it laying
out and mapping.
There's routines and there's patterns of success,
you know,
uh,
there are higher percentage drills and combinations that have been proven to be
successful.
Well how about we just keep practicing those,
but obviously it's up to the athlete to find the time,
the distance and accuracy to pull them off.
But they're,
they aren't part of the billing information.
We have to believe in the system too.
I can't be like,
like if I didn't believe exactly what Dwayne was telling me or that he can see
it,
that I know he can see it cause he's good at it.
Like are why are you really going to go out there and do what he says?
That's one thing I had with boss too.
Whenever he gave me information.
I did not doubt it at all as I know he's been there and done that and it wasn't
stuff that he felt he would do his stuff that he knew that I should do.
Right.
And I feel like understand Tj and I could give him the proper information for
the proper time,
but also I know when to sit back and let them flow as well.
Right.
And,
and when,
uh,
when to chip in and give them information and he's really good about,
you know,
receiving information as a case in point.
The first fight with Cody between the rounds,
we have drastically changed things and what we needed to change with just the
timing of our attack.
It's pretty simple to me.
Fighting is now I,
I don't,
I don't think I know it all.
I mean,
I know,
I don't know it all,
but it's all I know and I know a lot,
that's for sure.
But,
uh,
I was going back to earlier traveling out here three days a week and back home
four days again,
I found a really good fuck.
Slow Down with what you've done great for.
One was I found a good rhythm of us as far as pulling off information as far as
the path,
the class sparring and this was like we're layering it up,
we're practicing it in class,
now we're sparring with it and then going back to what we need to work on.
So I found a really good pyramid too for Tj to retain or for anyone to retain
the information.
It kind of condensing it to three days.
It's,
it was,
it was really fun.
It was,
I look at it as a,
as an experiment.
What's the most optimal way for someone to perform in fight safe and effectively
it's fun.
I love this shit.
There's a lot of people that want to go to these big giant super camps and I
know,
you know with Alpha male you were in a big giant super camp you're doing now is
very different and that's,
this is something that obviously steeped Emile Church was doing.
There's a lot of other funders that we're doing that are doing where a lot of it
is based around them.
Mighty mouse in particular.
That's,
so he's another one.
I mean there are a an unquestionably professional fighters around them,
but it's not like they're in a building with six other world champions and is a
bunch of savages that are coming up that you know and everybody's trying to kill
each other.
It's a,
it's a different,
it's a different set up.
Like it's,
a lot of it is geared towards you.
It is and it's just the national way it kind of have happened this time cause
this better.
What is better?
Is it better to be in the dog house with all the Alpha male guys where it's all
just animals trying to kill each other while yes,
for quantity,
yes.
If it's,
if it's not for money,
you know what I mean?
When these big gyms turned into something that wants
to make money,
then the real martial arts comes out of it.
When you have coaches and people running it that are really going to not want
to,
like I have a gym,
the training lab.
So I'm very fortunate that I have Steve Martin,
I guys will spin,
he's put his heart and soul into this thing to keep this building open because
we're not making money.
We're not,
we're not,
we're not gonna help.
We don't have a,
it's pretty much private teach a kid's class and we do adult boot,
a boot camp kind of things just to turn the lights on just so the bills are
paid.
And then some sponsors here and there to pay the coaches.
Like we're losing money and,
and thank God that we have a guy like Steve Martin.
It's willing to see our dream that we want to build a team that is not based
around money,
that it's uh,
um,
whatever money we didn't make it from the gym is going every dollar to the
coaches,
you know,
like I don't want them to,
I don't want to make money.
I don't want that awkward relationship between me.
And why aren't you letter that I'm making money off him?
You know what it mean,
then you get that weird business relationship rather than us just having a real
relationship.
Like me wanting him to get better,
him wanting me to get better,
which I felt like maybe you used to kind of be that way.
Alpha male,
but it's turned into a money thing to wear it.
I Dunno man.
It wasn't like there wasn't like before we,
before we got Duane,
we had no coach.
It was just us coaching each other kind of thing.
You know?
That's not usually the best thing.
No,
we were just beating each other.
We were sparring four or five days a week.
Yeah,
dude do.
I mean I picked up stuff fast because of it,
you know,
like you had to learn how to fight and I'm aggressive and I liked that stuff.
But it's not smart,
you know,
in terms of like your overall health,
their longevity in the sport,
you know?
Um,
yeah.
So I,
I,
I've control,
I've turned into a real professional athlete's sport.
Instead of it just go into the gym and going Ham.
Like I can go everywhere from my diet,
everywhere from the way I work at the Times.
I work out my schedule,
my recovery,
um,
have,
luckily I'm having Duane is able to travel out with me.
Um,
I built a,
I built an awesome facility right now with Mark Munoz,
circling back around being a coach,
Joe Christian fleet today,
Monica and all these guys,
like it's not money driven so it's,
it's doing great right now.
We're,
we're,
we're awesome.
We're doing awesome.
Yeah,
he really does have a really good crew of people around him in,
in all citizen Yorba Linda.
We're in Anaheim and all beautiful.
Yeah,
that's great.
So when the UFC is in Anaheim,
you're a hop,
skip and a jump away.
Oh yeah,
we're right there.
I mean even finding an la was nice.
I mean,
you know,
tend to fly,
knew where it was cool to find your backyard.
Dan Lambert did,
did all this before anybody.
I mean Dan Lambert in terms of like throwing money at things and putting
American top team.
I mean,
that guy,
he,
he spent a fuck load of money,
put fighters on salary and then recently built a giant place with dormitories
and everything.
You know,
that guy at all of the people that he's,
uh,
probably the pioneer of digging deep into his wallet and putting together a
crazy gym set up like that different kinds of crew,
you know,
you go down there,
then there are a ton of world champions.
There's a ton of professional athletes and you know,
it's,
you're not necessarily going to get the singular specified training that you're
getting right now.
Yeah,
for sure.
And then,
but we're also really,
so yeah,
you can be really good and we want you in our gym,
but if you have the right personality as well too,
it's not only about your skill to become a train with their gym and be a pro
athlete there.
We also got a vibe with us.
If we don't have the vibe,
then it's all egos are going to get involved and the gym's going to split up.
This guy's going to go here,
this guy's going to go there.
So how do you determine that?
Do you get to know them first and then let them in the jail?
We always let everyone in to see how they're going.
If they don't work out,
then we tell him like,
hey man,
this isn't the spot for you.
We don't,
we don't have an open spot.
You can see it with the drills and the Dutch Bros and just the drilling in
general how caring and somebody is.
Right and right.
There's,
there's four rules.
Ask My guys to follow.
And there are rules that revolve around accountability.
It's a show up on time.
Get better,
get tired,
take care of your partner.
You do those four simple things and we're good.
It's pretty simple.
Hmm.
Those are very good rules.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's a sport that attracts people who are troubled.
Yeah.
Agreed.
The rounds of the misfits.
Yeah.
And then it's happened that have been abused.
They want to get people back.
You know,
there's a lot of that.
You remember a lot of when,
when I was younger,
the more aggressive mean are people.
When you would find out more about them,
he'd find out there was child abuse.
Dad used to beat him up.
Stepdad beat him up.
There was always something that they were trying to get back at people for.
I feel like this sport is changing enough now that it's a very common thing that
kids want to do.
It's now you have,
you know,
kids with the good breath brings wanting to do it.
Yeah.
It's a challenging possible career now.
And a in a fighter,
you know,
a young kid coming up see someone like you and they go,
oh,
can you look at this guy?
He's two time world champion.
Super respectful,
articulate,
real friendly,
doesn't have a chip on his shoulder,
likes,
you know,
shaking hands and taking pictures and being around people.
Oh you don't have to be an asshole.
Like you don't have to be some brooding asshole for sure.
Yeah.
I mean you'll get paid for it in one of these days,
but yeah.
That's interesting,
right?
If you get paid more for being a complete asshole,
you know,
and make,
if you don't mind making a fool of yourself,
then you get paid more.
You know,
like Colby.
Yeah.
To the extreme.
To what?
Like what?
Come on Colby.
So hilarious.
I don't know.
I think it's funny,
man,
when I actually went to the fucking White House and put the thing on Donald
Trump's desk getting the belt,
I was like,
that is hilarious.
He actually did it.
Yeah.
You know,
it really,
really be funny.
If it turned out,
was this whole time he was a Democrat and this is all just a big act.
It's really super pro gay rights and put a bit of a women's team in the office.
He'd be a Democrat and then whoever's in the office as well.
He's just doing it only specifically just for promotion.
Yeah.
Him and Tyron Woodley's going to be co Raisie.
That's going to be crazy.
So you get no,
the videos on the Internet,
the one a black dude that says I'm Tyrone and fuck this or fuck that,
whatever.
You know,
you know the Internet guy.
Oh,
they're hilarious.
Can you pull up one of those videos of tie around this?
So funny,
but would you two would've been funny.
I'm sorry.
You got to explain what you fuck.
You're talking about so
hilarious.
Right?
Watch it.
He'll pull it up.
But uh,
it would've been a no,
no.
Do you know what I'm talking about Jamie?
You do.
Goodness.
Okay.
So watch this first.
Watch one of these,
give me some,
I'll give you sip.
Hold on.
Go bring him from the beginning.
This is a long compilation of it.
He just like kind of walks around and bullies people sorta
kind of a joke.
Is that,
is that him though?
That's not the regular tyrona
this is another one is a different guy.
Yeah.
This is a different one than the other ones that he's a different guy.
He'll do,
he'll go,
I mean you just type in Tyrone black dude in the Internet.
I mean you're going to get a lot of it.
So it would have been funny cause if that's not the best clip,
uh,
cause if he would have won the belt,
but no,
he wanted the boat rides.
I'm Tyrone and this is my motherfucking bill.
So if you watch these videos and actual good video of the Tyrone and Tyrone
would do that and the cage.
I was,
I've been thinking about this for a while and I shouldn't have been so fucking
funny,
but it's not funny.
He's one of the damn videos.
Shit,
Jamie,
pull that up.
I watched the Rogan show.
That was the guy who I think I'm gonna Steal your line was that's hilarious.
Yeah.
To,
he was almost after he won.
Like,
like nothing happened.
He just,
he knew it.
Right.
It's just weird.
You know this is another one.
That's him.
Is it the same guy?
Yeah.
This is one where he gets beat up for saying,
Oh really?
Oh,
here it is.
Look in Mama.
Fuck,
fuck.
Yo,
what's up?
What's up?
We'll make them all up.
Let's do something
comes out wrong.
Like
terrible editing.
There's this funny shit,
right?
But it seems like he's just mean and stealing.
I don't think that's funny.
No,
they're funny.
They're funny.
He's a mean scaler.
Oh Shit.
Okay,
let's kill this and not as funny as I thought.
Sorry guys.
Roll the funny shit.
It seems like a bad sketch.
Some of them,
not that guy.
No,
he's not a little bit funny.
It would probably sell more tickets for sure.
Yeah.
See that's where it tied in from like super calm and respectful.
It's hard to believe he was just in a cage fight.
Yeah Dude,
he shut all that Darren till hype up quick.
I knew it was going to win.
I would like to talk to Tyrone or do can see it.
Sorry to interrupt and because how we caught him,
because Darren too,
I made a video about this.
How Darren toe typically likes to fate and pumping.
Get the guy backing up,
get them out of position and then land the cross.
If we know from open stance from southpaw and there was a slight delay between
those two to three punches that he throws and I'm wondering if Tyrone does
research and seeing that Tyron is he say Tyrone now Tyrone is not coming down.
Mr Woodley,
right?
It's tiring.
Would Tyron,
Tyron,
there's no to that.
Now the joke when I'm in,
it's funny.
Kyron so that's what
you're saying.
I'm wondering if he,
if he,
if you read that from watching the videos previously and seeing that little gap
in the,
in his combinations they able to beat him to the punch or if you just duck and
chucked.
I'm curious to see if that was something that they trained in sought out or
cause that takes balls,
right?
These coming in with his strongest punches,
cross these knocked many people out with and he just stepped into it and beat
him to the punch that that takes balls.
Tyron does is he always used that strategy of standing against the fence or
close to the fence.
And then when guys move any counters,
I mean he did that with Josh Koscheck.
He's done that with a lot of guys and Rory Mcdonald was the only guy to shut
that down.
He figured out a way to shut it down.
He stayed long,
stayed long.
He's a lot of front kicks about jabs.
Keep kept his uh,
left hand up high to block a,
the right hand,
you know,
the big right hand.
But man you is just faster than him.
Way Faster.
Closed like lightning landed.
That right hand beat the shit out of him on the ground.
It was just shocking to me that Darren didn't know what to do when he was on his
back.
Like in terms of like that type.
That's how I thought the fight was going to go.
Like him just be on top of him.
The whole fight.
I thought Tammy was just going to and be on top.
Well I thought maybe that was part of the strategy too,
especially when you saw them warming up cause Taryn was doing like a lot of like
exchanges and then shoots for a double or closes the distance level changes.
Like they did that when he was working with um,
a boxing coaches as well.
He would hit the,
hit the meds and then move in a level change together.
But I was just,
um,
like till didn't understand the Darce was coming or didn't know.
But then you got to wonder how battered was.
He took that big shot,
took a lot of hard elbows on the ground.
How much was he really there?
That's the beauty.
I'm sorry.
No,
I was going to say because that Doris was a mile away.
I mean it was there and then it was there and then he cinched it up deep.
It was never like there was never a separation,
never pull in the hands back.
There was think Tyron is a lot stronger than him to be able to hold him in that
current position.
You know that he's a freak.
He's a beast.
It isn't why he's the champion,
but I think that's the,
well the way I choose to look at it any way is having a checklist.
Right?
If you were to build up a mixed martial artists,
how much information should they know?
Standing wrestling and then on the,
and this she just check,
check,
check and know all these basics should be covered before ego fight as a beauty,
beauty of having a curriculum and again,
a checklist.
No,
I absolutely agree with you.
I think you know,
understand it.
I mean the days of just like being able to just fight someone and not know
anything about them.
That seems kind of foolish.
Yeah.
Like,
it seems like a massive advantage to study.
Like when cowboy fought Darren till he decided to not watch any tape on him.
He's like,
you know,
here's the striker good.
I loved strike.
Okay,
might want to watch this Stryker.
Yeah,
I'll watch taping the beginning with Dwayne.
But then I kind of let him continue from there,
you know?
And I trust his judgment on everything.
Um,
and then when I'm out of fight camp since like,
cause sometimes when you watch a tape in fight camp,
like you can mess with people's heads,
you know,
like the maybe maybe cowboys getting too nervous and then when he's white gives
him to watch the fight.
You know,
you need to have it.
If that's the case,
you know,
have a coach that's willing to,
that you trust to do that for you.
That's a good point.
Now cause let me do this.
A mental,
this fucking sports,
a mental mind.
Fuck man.
You know,
of course,
whatever works the best for you.
Is that what you got to figure out?
Is it better for you to fight someone like Cody that you have all this animosity
and beef towards and all this shit talking cause you get super hyped up and
motivated every day?
Or is it better to fight someone who you have a lot of respect for was just a
good challenge?
I think a,
you got to learn to like to be the same person for every fight.
I think it's like control those emotions.
You know,
even if there was all that coming in,
like I'm nervous to fight,
you know,
like forget all the bullshit,
you know?
And I had to learn that through my career.
I had to learn to take emotion out of it.
And even in sparring still,
you know,
like John's always telling me,
control my emotion,
a controlled aggression,
you know,
cause you hit me,
I want to hit you back.
I'm very competitive.
So it's something you have to learn how to control.
And I've had to do that throughout my career.
Um,
and I think everyone has to learn to control either to let go or to pull back.
You know,
I'm like really control that emotion to be the same person every fight,
you know,
mentally,
not the same person,
every five a mentally like in your own head,
the same person,
but technically need to be able to switch it up.
That the mental aspect of it is probably the thing that holds more people back
then anything like we all know of guys that are just monsters in the gym and for
whatever it was when they would go to compete,
they just could never be their full self.
Yeah.
Tj does better in the cage.
Yeah,
it doesn't.
The Gym.
Yeah,
I was.
I did better in the,
in the gym then in the cage.
What do you think it is that makes you do better?
I love it.
I don't know and I've just taught myself to love this shit like I am.
I'm like,
I don't know when I get out there it's just like I want to be there.
You know?
Like,
I know everyone's nervous and like they're like,
it's the highest highs.
But I used to be so nervous that I forget like what happened in the fight,
you know?
But throughout my career,
I think after the Mike Easton fights,
when I really started to like hone in our,
during the Mike Easton fight is when I really started to hone in and have fun
and uh,
just realize like,
fuck this shit man.
Like what's the worst is going to happen?
They knocked out row for it,
you know?
How's his Funky Easton?
I Dunno.
How has it been around for a while?
Yeah.
I'm not really sure.
There's a possible super fight with you and Henry.
So who the hell he ain't talked about?
Hell yeah.
What'd you find them at?
One 25 25 s yeah,
absolutely.
I don't want no excuses that I'm the bigger man and he probably is bigger than
you,
quite honestly.
Yeah.
That's what I'm saying.
Like 20 struggles to get to 34 from a two down to 25,
25 or 30 especially with the coach I have now.
Sam Kalvia.
It's like,
well,
I was told I was going to fight Demetrius Johnson the summer before I fought
Cody the first time because Cody had to pull out because this was back within
three weeks of time.
I got down to waking up to 140 pounds by changing my,
the way I'm working out,
changing my calories,
changing my macro nutrients and uh,
myself like just going full bore.
Like I was able to start waking up in the morning 140 pounds within three weeks.
And so right now you're about 10 plus pounds heavier than that.
And how much time would you need?
Like if they said,
hey,
December 31st New Year's Eve.
Super Fun.
Yeah,
my coach,
my coach always wants to like the like actual,
like he told me like before,
after my last fight,
I mean,
he's 16 weeks,
but I mean,
obviously we could do it a lot fast.
I could've made 25 cents last fight,
um,
with how much water I had in me.
The,
the,
the hydration that he's got me going on when I get close to a fight too,
is it's easiest.
I don't do,
I don't you do baths anymore.
Like I to make weight.
I walked on the treadmill with plastics for how long?
Um,
the day of,
I'd say 30 minutes.
I sat in us on a little bit.
So you're only losing like four or five pounds most,
right?
Yeah.
In the morning.
Probably like three or four or five pounds.
Yeah.
That's,
that's a massive benefit to you in terms of your conditioning.
Oh,
huge.
He ain't having fluid on your brain,
your cardio,
you're muscular contraction in the endurance.
I mean,
everything.
when you deplete yourself like that,
like you're talking about during until maybe cutting too much weight,
I could definitely be a possibility,
you know?
I mean,
he's huge tills.
A big guy to get down to one 70.
Yeah.
I mean that is the,
it's the trying to find the right balance where you're big for the weight class,
but you're not diminishing yourself really drastically to get down to your
weight class in the hinders did thing also entertains me so much cause he's a
gold medalist and he wants to,
he wants to claim himself as the greatest combat athlete ever.
I'm a UFC champion.
I'm a gold medalist.
Like I'll go out there and beat you in wrestling.
MMA wrestling is completely different.
I'm the better athlete I'm going to.
I could beat him anywhere.
I know I can watch him fight.
Um,
so that's why I'm very excited about,
I think it's the greatest thing for my name right now.
Um,
I,
I'm very,
it excites me a lot.
Excites me a lot too,
to be able to show the science behind,
not only myself and my coach and,
and,
and Dwayne in the system,
like every,
like I'm all in,
dude,
whatever we're doing,
I'm 100% and I don't take any shortcuts and uh,
I want to show that I'm going to show that I could make 20 fives and be my best
ever as well.
Now Demetrius is injured.
Yeah.
Right.
He's,
he's out for a little while.
So this is one of the reasons why the Talker,
the super is coming up.
Yeah.
Like it is Demetrius gonna need a few months.
So you can't have an immediate rematch.
So have they talked to you about it?
Proposed?
You know,
there's been some,
there's nothing been like serious,
but there's been like a hints and like we did our media tour together and they
put us on camera together and had us talk shit to each other.
Nice.
I mean they didn't like,
they didn't say that,
you know what I mean?
Cause everything's real.
Everything we do is real,
but it's like,
oh shit,
this is what you guys want.
You know?
And like,
you really think you could beat me then fuck you man,
let's do this shit.
You know,
like that's where I get my motivation from,
from fighting is,
is not the anger,
not it's,
it's the,
the competition.
And does he want to go to 35 is that he told me face to face.
He's willing to do at 25 25 yeah.
Yeah.
That's when he first set up to the fights that he wanted.
He wanted to the super fight.
Right.
That's what he's his idea.
So he said come to 35 so I told him,
I'm like,
look for doing this.
I'm coming to 25 so I have no problem with that.
He's got more street credit to drop the divisions.
Division j right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It gives you more street crash for sure.
Well
the bigger man,
I don't want him to come 35 then you whip his ass to be like,
oh well he's cause he's a 35 pound year.
He's a 35 pound or two I'll whoop your ass.
He,
he's a huge one.
20 fiver.
Hmm.
He really is.
Can you take out the weight cutting?
Just not much difference between you two guys.
Yeah.
And when you stay then how much better I am.
Oh,
that's true.
Ooh Henry,
hang on.
Um,
but when you saw him and Demetrius together,
I mean he's a much bigger person.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He,
well,
how much weight did he lose?
Yeah,
so I don't know.
Good question.
He's gotta be in the 50s when he shows up to fight week.
He looks like he's cutting weight already.
You know when I show up to fight week,
I haven't even really started yet,
Ma.
Yeah.
I mean for your,
your pace and your endurance,
that's gotta be a big benefit to know that your body is 100% healthy going in
there in terms of like not being dehydrated and there's so many guys,
you see them on the day of the way and you go,
I don't know how the fuck you going to fight in 24 hours.
I think head traumas a lot more prevalent when you're dehydrated.
They going through camp like I've known some guys that have cut a lot of weight
and it's already have hindered their careers.
And you know,
because you're having those all out spars,
I mean,
you're going,
you have to go as hard as you can and sparring money ready for a fight.
Like you're going for your timing,
you're going for,
you're fighting,
right.
I mean,
you don't do it all the time.
We,
there's,
there's times when you're sparring,
you're sparring like a fight for the most part.
I mean,
I'm not larger gloves or,
uh,
no.
Well,
we've been doing smaller Gulf and aspiring to,
but those,
those puffy that I have,
they are,
uh,
I feel like as padded as my 16th.
It depends where,
it depends on where they put the padding.
Padding on the knuckles,
I mean,
not thicker than 16 months.
Companies,
gloves to use for that animal.
Santa Ball.
Always tenable.
Yeah.
The one you had w where's that from?
Um,
well their offices in New York,
but the guy,
the owner is living out here in California.
Is that a new company?
It's been around.
It's fresh.
It's somewhat new.
It's not brand new.
I think they've been around since 14,
14.
But yeah,
I make great stuff.
I mean they have,
they're puffy sparring.
Gloves are awesome to bill to get,
uh,
to get real rounds in.
Cause when I grapple I can't,
I can't do fully made rounds with a big puffy clothes on boxing gloves.
Those,
they're puffy around the knuckles.
But you still grip with them?
Yeah.
So grew up with them and got everything.
I mean,
the only thing that's different is like the padding on your,
uh,
I for like can't you don't throw him but like having your face or your thumb,
you gotta be careful with your thumb so you really have to be accurate with your
punches.
And I'm with does it fuck with you if you're working submissions with the extra
padding on the knuckles?
Absolutely.
I mean we're naked.
Chokes are harder to get the hand behind the head and guys,
guys can get out of submissions easier because they can grab more of the glove
even though they're not supposed to.
Can I say something real quick because Tj was saying that,
you know,
as far as hard sometimes.
Right.
So I tried to have,
my guys don't want to say it and so a sparring hard,
you do have to spar hard,
but we would have him do that once a week.
But we do a whole bunch of sparring drills throughout the week as well to get
better technically understand the distance and the timing.
But you do need to spar hard,
but it's not like you're hurting the guy if he's rocked or whatever.
You're not getting,
not going to knock him out,
but you'll still on with with good forced too because you do have to experience
that for sure.
But rocks,
you just hit him to the bottom right?
No,
for sure.
Yeah.
If you were coming,
you know,
heard him to the body and the suddenly I'll say get hit her to the body and you
know,
work out of that as well.
Don't,
don't take a knee.
Wanted to make sure that was clear because that's one of the things I feel I've
been able to do is
dissect the chaos of a fight and slowly manipulatives so we can actually
understand the layers and get better at it.
And that helped a lot with the actual drilling and sparring,
drilling and sparring and then the fight itself.
So understand that latter process.
Have you ever
on any core drills or ab drills that allow you to absorb punches or kicks
better?
Is there anything that you've shown if you ever figured out,
I don't know if it does do it.
I mean we have a coach throws medicine balls against,
we're like we're doing motion movements are doing on a balancing and a tire or
doing it almost like a burpee motion or something.
Getting back to your feet and slam it like a big medicine ball and your stomach.
I mean I think,
I just think the impact without hurting yourself is going to help ultimately and
then just having a stronger core in general.
I think,
I think core is by far the most important and in May and Jujitsu and in
grappling is your core strength is how strong your core is,
is like,
cause I can go and lift weights and this guy's going to be way stronger than me
doing bench or doing a dead lifts,
whatever it may be.
But we get on the mat and he's like,
dude,
how the fuck are you so strong?
I think it's all core.
It's certainly,
there's a lot to do with kicking power.
So it's so much of it.
It's not just the legs,
it's the ability to whip this to hips into it.
All this,
that's all your core and your cardio.
It controls your breathing.
Um,
I think it's really,
I believe quarters and everything.
What kind of exercises are you doing for that?
This is endless.
I mean a lot of medicine ball stuff.
Are you doing different things with Mr Colavito?
Yeah.
You doing before?
Yes.
Yeah,
completely.
Um,
actually the shit's crazy.
Yeah.
It's straight up crazy man.
Like I've like the first time I showed up I knew it was going to be hard.
Like I've always told me like,
oh,
he's like,
you go hard man.
Like I've never gone to heart as hard as it,
this guy pushes me ever in my life from the all the years of me practicing.
You're competing,
but it,
it,
you can only do it so many times.
You can't do it all the time.
And he knows when,
when the next practice should be easier or when we're going to have those days
where I'm for sure going to throw up,
you know,
or like what days I'm pushing a sled up the hill.
Uh,
we do a lot of,
um,
cycling now I'm on the bike constantly,
but it's not only for low base,
at certain power intervals,
doing distance,
like actual bike on the road or the idea that too.
Um,
so if I,
if I fight 25,
so I'll be doing a lot of roadwork,
um,
running swimming.
I'm privileged to try to make 25,
it'll be a triathlete as well.
I'll be doing some Cameron Hanes shit.
Well,
I only run in that fire,
but I'll be trying to act like Cameron Hanes,
um,
to get smaller.
But,
uh,
yeah,
so the,
I think the bike work does a lot for our core as well too,
because your core is not only your stomach,
you know,
and of course from your hamstrings up to your back,
throughout your career,
throughout your stomach,
it's,
it controls a lot,
you know.
So even even doing the bike work is,
is a lot of it
court work as well too.
Yeah.
People don't realize that sometimes when you have lower back pain it's cause
your hamstrings are too tight.
Yeah.
You tell him that and like what?
And then they learn how to stretch out their hamstrings and like,
yeah,
my back feels better.
Yeah.
So Yoga is all about,
man,
hell yeah,
we do,
we do yoga.
I mean everything.
I mean there's,
there's so much beyond what we have to do.
And how long has this guy been doing this?
So Mark Munoz was his first,
um,
project and may he wrestled.
And so he was a wrestler.
He wrestled the,
I'm always been around wrestling and he's helped mark with his wrestling camps.
Um,
his kids.
Right.
So he's got that wrestling mentality.
Um,
but then he's just a genius as well.
And so his first projects was Mark Munoz when he was making weight and looking
shredded,
the Tim Boetsch fight,
things like that.
That was when you first started helping out.
So that's why it's called the training lab as well as spelled with rain in the
middle,
um,
is because he was attached to Mark Munoz as Jim and helping him out and Mark
Munis jam for people will know it was called rain.
Yes.
Rain.
Yeah.
And so I think that it's funny,
it's come full circle.
I mean,
Mark Munoz is the one that talked me into fighting.
He's my coach at cal state Fullerton wrestling.
Um,
and he was in the UFC at the time,
was my assistant coach after I graduated college,
like all bummed out.
I didn't do like what it should have.
And so I didn't feel like I was done competing sort of fallen mark around and
doing Jujitsu and all this shit.
And I was actually enrolled in Grad school at the same time to become a
physician's assistant.
He pretty much talked me into dropping out of school and give him a fighting
chance because he thought I'd be good at it and now it's come full circle and
now he's our coach again.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's got some awesome MMA flow drills.
Mark Munoz.
Yeah.
It's been good wrestling forum in May.
You can't just be like a nice,
awesome wrestler and come in and teach him and everything.
You know,
you gotta know how to punch.
You got to know the Jujitsu aspects of it.
Um,
MMA wrestling,
it's its own sport or,
yeah.
Well it certainly,
there's certainly rules that you have to file that you don't have to fall and
regular wrestling things,
you know,
that's the case.
Would you Jitsu as well.
It certainly helps to learn Jujitsu.
One of the things,
I don't know if you guys are paying attention to,
but Eddie Bravo came up with a thing called Combat Jujitsu,
which is sort of an intermediary step between regular Jujitsu and MMA.
And it's basically Jujitsu with bitch slabs.
Pancreas.
Yeah.
But some of those bitch slaps the poms.
Well,
boss figured out how to do it.
He figured out how to pull his hands way back and he was basically punching you
with his palm where you could hit anybody.
Anywhere you get to hit him in the forehead,
you'd have to,
you don't have to worry about your knuckles.
I feel like that's harder than my MMA glove.
Yeah,
I think so too.
Yeah.
I mean you could really put a beating on somebody with palms is an innovator for
sure.
He's a boy.
He taught me how to think,
how to be open minded and figure stuff out.
Yeah,
so here it is.
This is combat.
You just do it.
That's a guy on the ground,
I think.
I hope
Donald Harrison,
this is otherwise it's fucked up.
That one to pick up Jamie.
That's where the whole equal attacking the leg situations,
James's actual fight and you have hunches,
right?
Yeah.
They watch attacking those legs.
I mean you,
you opened up things the same way you would open up things with punches.
You know there is Bam is that one of my affiliate students from Montana with the
blonde hair barring the roaches stopped quite a few people.
While he's topped at least one person with just a slaps.
But he's used those slaps.
No.
And Wagner has a,
he's got a big advantage in being a high level MMA fighter as well heading into
this.
But there,
um,
the idea behind it was created by Eddie because he wanted to make it just a
little bit more realistic on the ground.
Add this other element to it because there's times where guys are going for leg
locks and you know your,
your face is wide open.
You're committing both your arms to the person's leg and that person's in a
position where they could just smash your face.
And if you're used to that in Jiu Jitsu gym where a guy can punch you and you
just think you're safe and you always practice in that way.
Thank you.
Combat Jujitsu is a real wake up call and just getting fucking,
and
the argument goes instructor at our art academy,
Sam Kootz,
he teaches Jujitsu for self defense and then he asks you if you want to compete
in Jiu Jitsu.
They teach two different Jujitsu.
He wants to figure out,
find out why did you come here,
what your,
you want to get better,
you want to jump the fence,
you want to compete because there's a different way you have to approach things
for sure.
Which is why Tj can be on the same mat with regular students in my gym because
he's doing slightly,
have a different drill in combination with more contact than the average person,
you know.
So you'll get out what you put in and in your academy,
do you have everything there?
Do you have submission instruction,
wrestling or do you go different places for you Jujitsu?
How do you do it?
Uh,
the only thing I do,
I'm not at my gym is my Jujitsu.
I go to Gracie Baha and Irvine with a flip it and Monica.
Great spot.
Yeah man,
he's,
he's a straight up an engine.
He knows Jujitsu for MMA.
Just like you're saying.
Mark Munoz wrestling for MMA and I probably have striking for him away.
He,
Tj has a really good camp around him.
I would have liked to be in his position.
Now with the understanding of martial arts.
I'm not gonna hijack podcast.
Sorry,
I'm just so happy for him
is,
I mean,
like I told him the other day,
we were texting about like Tammy were meant for this shit in music has video.
It's like,
dude,
this is our journey though.
You know,
like this is,
I'm not doing this shit alone.
If I was doing it alone,
it'd be a lot harder.
I'm not saying I couldn't do it by where I don't,
I wouldn't be to this level.
I wouldn't be who I am.
I told him this is our journey,
you know,
I mean that's why this shit works cause I don't have a bigger ego.
I'm not like whatever.
You know that me and Dwayne really see eye to eye and I family now,
he's family now.
So it's,
it's so critical the relationship that you guys have because I think it's,
there's,
he can add so much in terms of what he understands and your acceptance of him
and your appreciation of him allows you guys to like fully integrate to this one
project of Tj Dillashaw world champion making you the best you could be if there
was any sort of conflict or you gotta be number one or you don't want to listen
to him.
I'm going to do what I want to do today.
Like that shit happens all the time with coaches and fighters and fighters.
And then sometimes you don't hear about it until after the fight and you're
like,
what happened?
I gotta tell you man,
it wouldn't show up for training.
He was this and that.
He's
got this new girlfriend,
she's pregnant and blah,
blah,
blah.
That's why I'm all in because Tj is all in.
Yeah.
Dot.
I don't have a vast stable of fighters.
I have a few guys that float through my place.
Right.
I worked with them a little bit here and there,
but Tj is all in,
so I'm all in
now.
One of the benefits of being in Colorado was the altitude.
Are you?
You don't think so?
No.
It depends where he fight.
What do you think?
Because you can train a lot harder at sea level.
Your body gets a little more dance,
like the oxygen and your recovery at sea level is way better.
I mean,
when I first started going up to Colorado and training at altitude,
I felt like my body wasn't recovering as I felt older man cause a lack of air up
there.
Yeah.
I think the lack of,
of rebuilding myself,
you know,
we do altitude training,
we do altitude,
it's called Alto lab.
Something I breathed into at certain times,
certain time links,
um,
to really like different intervals throughout the,
throughout training camp.
Um,
instead of living in,
in breathing altitude,
I'd really get to recovery and the hard training from sea level and then use the
altitude to get in that hypoxic state.
So the reason why less auction air,
you create more red blood cells.
And the more red blood cells you have,
the more oxygen you transport.
And so they're thinking if you go down to sea level,
you're going to have more oxygen to transport,
but your body hasn't able to train as hard in recover as it can at sea level.
And then use the hypoxic state by breathing in this machine to get the red blood
cell production.
Okay.
So you can get the benefit,
makes an altitude without having to live there.
What I had heard is that the best move was to train at sea level,
but live at high altitude.
I don't think,
I mean,
I don't think your recovery is good enough.
What about those?
And what my coaches told me,
you know,
it makes sense to,
this is making sense.
What do you think about those tents where people sleep in those tents?
I've tried one.
Um,
if it's hard to sleep because you're pumping it up so it gets hot in there for
one,
plus you start thinking like that scene in psycho with a fucking shower
surrounded my shower curtain.
Just have nightmares and shit every day.
But no,
uh,
it's when you're,
when you're not breathing as much oxygen,
it's just you don't feel recovered and you don't get a restful night's sleep.
I said,
you know,
I see.
I see what you're saying now.
That totally makes sense.
Yeah.
You definitely feel the difference.
Um,
and it totally makes sense that you would be able to train harder at sea level.
You can push your body to that super far extreme that you wouldn't be able to
get there,
um,
at altitude.
But it's live it out to two for a few years.
Doesn't your body totally normalized to that?
Yeah,
but then,
um,
but I'll be fighting at sea level.
You know,
I,
I don't,
you don't know.
Yeah.
I don't know enough to be handed.
That's just what I was told.
I know I need,
no matter where I'd fight.
Sorry.
Ninja.
Yeah,
you're good.
I knew no matter where I fought that I would always be ready to go because I was
born and raised in Colorado,
so I didn't care where it was.
And one of my goals was to get tired cause I knew if I was tired that that
motherfucker was dead tired.
So let's go.
Mm guys like Colivida make my head hurt.
Dude,
he's awesome about thinking about all these different things that he's got.
You go on and thinking about all his,
the planning that must be involved with full time jobs.
It's a straight up full time job.
Like even like the juicing I do every day.
I mean if I,
if he didn't do my meal prep it'd be impossible unless obviously my wife was
doing it all.
Um,
it'd be impossible to get all that done.
You know,
they're doing it.
It's so much.
And how many athletes is he working with?
It's a pretty small group.
I mean,
and is growing now because obviously the name is growing and more athletes that
were getting along those garage.
Yeah,
it's called the girl.
We do it at the gym as well too,
but there's a small group of guys that still go to his garage and do it there.
It's kind of like our,
our varsity team I guess you'd say,
you know.
Um,
once you,
once you've proved yourself enough in the gym,
you can get with that switch is happening.
Guys have come to our gym,
they've worked out with us,
we've got along with them.
They become like,
you know,
family and then we bring them into the garage.
Um,
so I'd say he's got c cub one,
Aaron Peko Saiad um,
just by,
I don't know,
I would say we're probably got like a nine guys will come to his garage and
workout.
That's a great group right there.
Have an Aaron Peko will be,
that's got to help that teacher world champion.
And without a doubt,
for sure the savage,
not only like how good he is technically,
but mentally to like do that fools.
I'm competitive.
I go hard.
And he's to another extreme.
Like,
dude,
it's,
we do this at Camp pedaler for distance at the garage.
We're on a down,
um,
a decline.
So our were downhill and we're doing his hand pedalers for distance and how far
we can get.
Who gets it?
Who gets to a mile first wins.
And I thought he won the world title when you beat me.
She stood up like,
yeah,
like,
like pretty much what I did to Cody yelled in my face after the fight,
you know,
like,
or after the ham had others that he won.
He,
he's just,
he's very competitive.
He's very good.
Technically he's hungry.
He takes no short case.
21 years,
21 years old and wasn't taking any shortcuts.
I didn't learn all this shit until I was 30 and he's already doing it now.
And he's a world class wrestler.
Um,
great boxers working with Freddie Roach a lot.
he's good man.
He's really good.
Yeah.
And you know,
I think there's a,
there's an actual real gift in losing his first fight.
Yeah.
I think there's a gift in that you learn much hype behind him and he got cracked
and submitted quick.
Hebrews got finished as the worst you could possibly get worst.
And it's very first fight in a head kick.
I don't really recover.
Only did you get knocked out,
but you got submitted as well and you did.
And you did it in front of Madison Square Garden on the main card for your first
fight ever.
So he experienced,
experienced like the lowest lows for his first fight.
So now it's like there's no going low or like everything's,
everything's skyrocketing now and everybody was so hyped up about them.
There was so much hype about them,
which is deserved,
but it just shows you that everybody can get caught,
anybody can get finished.
And that experience I think is so valuable for him.
Yeah,
I really do.
And that,
that left hook that he landed
in his last fight.
Holy Shit.
Two fights.
Huh?
My body nasty murders.
He'll find that body shot every time.
Respiring she's like,
obviously you got to get ready for it and you can feel it,
but he finds it every time.
Yeah.
You gotta be ready and then like you start worrying about the body shot and
you're opening yourself up,
you know,
so yeah.
Yeah.
He's,
he's good man.
He's really good.
That's one thing I was filling Mr Coker of Bella toward does pretty well is
gives people the proper fights and help build them up.
Right.
I don't think people's first fight with a bad matchup,
he just got caught.
You got caught and caught by a tough guy.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I love coker.
I like what he's doing and you know,
I'm supposed to be somehow or another and competitive competition with bell
tour.
I said it's horseshit.
I mean,
I'm the one who got Jimmy Smith hired.
I was trying to get them hired years ago.
I uh,
and I love the fact that big Johns over there now and that uh,
you know,
Gold Goldie's over there too and moral.
I love moral and I just,
there's a lot of great fighters over there,
man.
I mean,
I love the fact that Rory Mcdonald's over there,
that he's a champ.
I mean he's one of the,
if he's not the best welterweight in the world,
it's him and Tyron,
you know,
I really think that,
I really think I got to practice that name.
Sorry.
Tiring.
Just don't have any on the and there sir.
I'm on it.
But if it's not,
I mean he's most certainly one of the best moves.
Saucy,
one of the best one 85 ers in the world,
if not the best.
I mean they have like legit claim to world class fighters now and at least two
weight classes.
They got the banners,
the fighter walk out.
It's like an old school.
UFC.
I like it.
I like um,
you know that the fighters are having a good time over there.
They getting paid well I don't hear any complaints.
Yeah,
I want it to grow man.
I really want it to be,
I want it to be like right up there with the UFC.
I would love it if it was a full rival.
Like pride wise.
Yes man.
Ms Proud.
I left pride.
I didn't figure out a way to do that.
Crossover fights.
He can stay,
he could stay in Belgium,
jar bill,
Bill trip as far as UC is and then have like this like oh yeah we're fucking
better.
And those are big fights.
Canelo triple G.
Yes.
Look if they had a Floyd Mayweather versus Conor McGregor MMA style,
if there was like literally a guys bill talks about that.
Right?
Well there were talks about that for Floyd and Connor but I don't think it was
real.
What I mean is a guy who gets as big as Mayweather has gotten in the UFC and the
guy who gets his big as he got in MMA with belter and then they have some giant
ass fucking Superfight.
There's enough for everybody.
Yeah.
I just think for the athletes it's better if there's choices,
you know and it's,
it's good for you.
It's not just choices,
it's more competitive and when it's more competitive they try harder to do a
good job for the athletes.
Make it attractive to the athletes.
Like if you're a football player you can get,
you can go to a bunch of different places to play,
right.
But if you're a fighter,
you got like two spots,
you got bell tour and it got the UFC,
it starts,
it's like there's two teams out there and I think that's unfortunate.
I think it'd be way better for fighters.
I don't think that boxing is a clean system and I think boxing definitely has
its flaws in terms of like promotion and how fighters,
this is why this fights have happened in my triple g and Canelo when it should
already been over like triple g won that fight.
But that could happen in the UFC and does judging happens all the time.
There's some fucking terrible justice out there.
Yeah.
I mean we experienced that.
Fuck.
It's crazy man.
It's crazy that no one is doing anything to fix it.
There's people that have passed bad calls that should just be removed.
Yeah.
So you don't understand professional high level fighting.
They're just be like a grading system.
Like if you see these judges and they can,
they've made like,
look,
this person's made like for bad choices for bad decisions.
Right.
You're out.
I think they should go through a training course and be tested on it.
Just like I test my students for their making in the system.
Right.
They should be able to go through this information and get better and and under
and pass the test or not judge to the fight.
Or let a fight go through and let some quality judges judge it and then test
those results versus their results.
Right.
How do they judge it and compare those notes to see,
cause we're dealing with people's careers and their livelihood and lots on the
line with these people aren't making the correct decisions from their lack of
education.
They could definitely get better at.
So hopefully they start brewing.
Sorry.
Oh No,
please go.
When they start pointing some old fighters and old m maybe spiders retired
fighters as far as being the judges,
but then maybe there's some,
some uh,
hold back on that from what would you think?
A biased.
Yeah,
totally.
That's possible.
But I think you're better off with those fighters and their bias than someone
who really doesn't understand cause there'll be afraid of being called out to if
you can use usually like see their,
their decisions they're making like no,
just don't have them judge someone who they have a close relationship was her.
Right.
If like Frankie Edgar is fighting,
you don't have a car all made as a joke.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
Cause he's a part of the commission.
That's right.
Even though I think Ricardo was awesome,
the team,
you need people that understand martial arts and a lot of the people that are
judges that just have no background,
which to me is crazy.
Agreed.
It just doesn't make any sense when the,
it's not like there's a shortage of martial arts practitioners out there.
There's millions of us were out there.
You could find us and you could get us to be judges objects from fights.
Yeah,
there you go man.
I mean and,
and I think also we've said this before,
I'll say it again,
it should be more than three judges.
There's no reason to limit it to three.
All you need is two dummies and they ruin a fighter's career.
You know,
you could get bad luck and have two dummies out of three.
That's not hard to do.
Two people really don't understand the fight you,
you need at least five and I think we'd be fine with 10 I don't think there'd be
anything wrong with having 10 judges that way.
If you really got to five,
five,
that's a real draw.
And I think real draws are real too.
Like there's fights where like you go,
Jesus,
I don't know who won that fight I got,
I'd have to go over that fight with a fine tooth comb.
And the difference,
the distance between winning and losing is so close.
I think you're,
you're better off arguing for a draw in some fights.
I don't think there's any shame in that.
Yeah,
I agree 100% I mean,
if actually it was that close,
like why not it be it,
you know?
Yeah.
Because there's some fights where the guy gets a decision or the girl gets a
decision.
You're like,
how by who?
They both won.
I mean,
there's a fucking incredible fight.
One person goes home,
a loser,
the other person goes home a winner.
And it's almost like flipping a coin over time.
When I used to lose,
when I said draw over time,
Gloria does that still.
I would just say I came in second place and I tried to ease it a little bit.
Glory does still the one more round.
That's right.
Yeah.
I think that'd be cool.
Shit.
That was the one fucking wild.
Now it's like,
who I fucking won this one?
You know like,
Oh fuck,
we got another round.
Right.
Let's do this split decision.
I go,
Jesus,
we have a majority draw.
You're like,
oh no.
Audience would go nuts if you had that only for championships.
Yeah.
Only for championships.
One more round.
Yeah,
that'd be cool man.
People just start pounding on the ground and she'd be like a 10 minute round.
It should be a 10 minute round.
Two Oh fried style.
Pride style.
10 minute around was awesome for grapplers and the gloves to,
yeah.
Yeah.
You think that's a big factor,
right?
The curve of the gloves and I'm my boxing coach.
Trevor Whitman is working on some kind of gloves that are eliminating the IPOs
situation.
I'm not quite sure exactly what he's thinking,
but he,
if there's anybody to do that job,
it's him.
I love that dude.
He,
he is.
He is.
Why I'm as technical as I am is from Trevor Whitman.
He's very detailed.
One of the things that,
that a lot of people were like almost like wondering or down on him or trying
to,
looking for something to criticize.
It wasn't just engaging,
knocked out.
James Vick cracks up,
drops some,
smash them,
stops him.
Everyone is going crazy and look at Trevor Trevor just sitting there like this,
but he knows.
Yeah,
I mean he,
he didn't jump up and scream.
He's had his arms crossed and he's what you see if you can find that so you get
it.
Can you try to get back at it?
It's kind of ignited to,
not only do you expect it,
he was like quietly satisfied.
I was like,
look at that Tyron,
after his title,
he was like,
hmm.
Sorta just Whitley cried when he got his black belt.
That was crazy.
Thomas to fell a fighter like that.
That's awesome.
It's cool.
That felt more to him than win.
That's so crazy.
The Dow would feel more to him then then defending his title.
He's been real champion,
nosy world champ.
He's confident,
you know,
without a doubt.
One of the best welterweights of all times.
Without a doubt.
He's,
I feel like there's three guys in the running.
It's Matt Hughes,
George Saint Pierre and him.
He's so athletic,
man.
So good.
It's crazy authentic.
He is.
And with den with Dean and his corner and with Duke Roufus and just,
he's just coming into his own man.
You know,
he mean and people criticized him for the Damien Maia fight and the Wonderboy
Thompson fight.
But because those fights was boring,
that's the way you have to fight those guys period.
If you want to fight Wonderboy,
you think you get to go crazy and charge at him.
Good luck and good idea.
Yeah.
You're going to eat some knuckles to going back to the training method,
you know,
and that's one thing.
I wonder how much time it Duke is spending with him and,
and dean spending without Din Din Thomas Dennis spending with them and then
taking that skill and testing it against all the other att guys.
So I'm just wondering how much classwork is doing versus one on one work and
then how much live work is getting with the crew.
That's actually a question.
I don't think they're doing too much work att because atts where Colby is right
now.
So what?
Where's he now?
He's training that is that seem a lot of it at Duke roof.
Okay.
Spend a lot of time with Duke,
but I don't know exactly where he trained his whole camp.
You know,
he was at,
uh,
at Duke.
He was at Duke,
so yeah.
Good.
Well he looks fucking phenomenal.
Duke's figured out a way to get him to really conserve his energy and manage it
properly too,
because we all know that when someone's that big and that it's so hard to
maintain a durance,
but he hurt Wonderboy in the fourth round of their fight and hurt him bad.
Like he carries that knockout power deep,
deep into the fight.
So he's figured it out.
He's figured out a way to manage his energy correctly.
And if you see the countdown shows too,
he's doing a bunch of crazy crap strength and conditioning shit too,
which I kind of think everybody has to do now.
Right.
That's even,
that's a real,
we're going to ESPN.
It's a real fucking sport.
You know,
you can't take shortcuts,
man.
This is a professional,
like I told you,
my training schedule is a full time job.
It's hard for me to get anything else done when I'm in training camp.
Now when you're not training camp,
like now you're out of camp,
how many days a week you working out?
Um,
lately I've only been doing like my string conditioning with Sam.
So when I'm back in town a couple of times a week,
um,
I'm going to go back out to Colorado and I was spinning everyday at Dwayne's
doing kickboxing.
Um,
I'll probably go to start going to Gracie Baha,
send you this is all fun.
Like I'm doing,
I'm doing the normal.
I'll go to do normal class right now at Sam's.
It's not like I'm peaking for a fight,
so it's just maintaining my body and keep them certain things strong to prevent
injury.
Um,
and then I'll go to Gracie Baha and I'll probably roll some g just to do it,
you know,
just to kind of stay active.
When you roll gay,
do you grab the g or do you trust?
Just try to do Nogi techniques.
I need to get better at learning how to grab the key.
I just still do Nogi techniques because that's what I've always do.
You know I,
I'm never did.
I would never really use the gay.
I hardly ever use it.
It's not my favorite,
but I wear it but I don't use it.
Yeah.
I just do know [inaudible] with the Guiana and they'd grab me,
but I just do know geese stuff.
Yeah.
That's why I got to go in there for fun.
You can't go in there and like expecting to be great because there's so much
shit.
If you don't know it,
they're grabbing your belt,
pulling you in certain colleges and crazy shit that they deal.
They pull your,
your thing out at your lapels out,
tried to choke you with it.
They'll pull the back of your geek out,
wrap it around your neck.
Right arm,
right settle down.
But it mean for the geek competition,
as long as that's all legal,
that's great.
But I mean for someone learning martial arts,
whether it's for self defense or for me,
what I found about doing g is it really improved my Nogi submission defense
because it was so easy to control me with the gate.
Cause if someone's grabbing your collar and grammy your sleeve and they bang
their hold you down,
you have to get out of things.
Technically.
Like if you get locked up in an arm bar,
you can't just explode out of things.
You have to figure out a way to like slowly,
incrementally release yourself the right way and defend everything the right
way.
Because if you get too deep with all that friction with the,
you know that heavy canvas,
he,
they can lock you up.
You know,
I,
we to be technical and your defense really,
it makes you too much more meticulous about your submission.
So it doesn't make you like hold.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Especially defense.
Yeah.
I mean if you're going to compete in Jujitsu then where it Geeky,
but if it's for self defense,
then I would actually train Nogi I say that.
But if you're in New York and you wearing a leather coat winter to match what
Ronda Rousey's due to someone who had a winter coat on soc shit to her with a
Jean Jacket on,
bitch,
you fly on your head.
Hell yeah.
Hell yeah you are.
That's who they are.
Rolling with the typical close though.
Right?
Cause the that's going to be different than an actual but close enough if it's
enough the grab,
I mean you know like if your graph you could choke somebody out with a regular
collared shirt.
Oh you know you grab a hold of like a regular dress shirt and you get a hand in
lapel.
That's a dead man and he doesn't even know it.
Just get ahold of that collar and pull that fucker in a great,
I mean kind of like you were saying,
changing who I am because of of where I'm at my life and my family now.
Like I wish I could train more outside of fight camp.
I wish I had more time to get in the gym and train.
But I'm like going everywhere,
getting pulled in every direction,
creating businesses to try to set up my future.
I know you're,
you've got your season,
he'd business.
I've used your seasoning.
Yeah.
Flavors,
flavor republic.
Yeah.
Did you come up with this on your own?
So yes,
I started it because of my new diet with same cal Vieta you know,
I had to eat super clean,
I wanted a low sugar and I wanted something that was low sodium or no sodium so
that when I'm cutting weight I can still use it.
But we make our own sea salt,
organic sea salt as well so that we can add it to and we want to,
you know,
so that I,
because I,
you need sodium,
you need good sodium.
But when I'm wanting to flush the water I don't,
I don't use it.
So yeah,
you sent me over a bunch of stuff.
It's great man.
Thank you.
I use a lot of it.
Yeah.
Seasoned meat with it all the time.
Why just used it last night?
I mean,
it's not like I'm actually using,
I'm actually into the company and like it,
you know.
That's cool.
Especially for wild game and things like that.
It's cool man.
It's really,
really fun.
Do you,
uh,
do you have a pellet grill?
Do you cook with I do.
I have a trigger.
Those things,
that shit they sent me one of those,
those bad words,
those bad ass one.
You want to at timberline,
dude,
you got the meat thermometer.
Everything with this.
A lot of on that thing.
Best to,
well it's all wood.
It's natural wood for people to know what a pellet grill is and there's a bunch
of companies and make real good ones.
Uh,
we have outback,
we have a Yoder that's really good.
I had a green mountain grill.
That's a really good company that Green Mountain grills are very affordable too.
And they come also with a builtin thermometer.
Just like the trigger hounds.
Yeah.
What'd you do is you,
you pour wood pellets and these pallets are made,
like if someone makes a table like this,
the natural,
the saw dust from the,
an actual table is they just compress it and the natural sugars in the saw dust
force it to form into these little pellets,
these like little tubular pellets and you can snap them with your fingers,
you know,
but they,
they go through this worm drive onto a heating element and it's just fire and
wood.
That's all it is.
You're,
you're,
you're cooking your food with fire and wood.
I mean it's all complicated and electronic and shit and it's all sophisticated
in an engineered,
but at the end of the day,
the result is fire and wood and the food tastes like fire and wood.
Great.
That's what they like.
They have different pellets for different tastes.
You can taste the difference.
Absolutely.
I love pellet grills ma'am.
She was just such a big fan.
It's such an easy way to cook too.
And that,
that timberline just maintains its temperature perfectly.
You could start it with your phone
connected to your phone.
So if you want to heat it up before you get home,
you can start heating it up.
[inaudible] they have an APP,
like I was going to cook lobster tail,
so I'm like,
Ooh,
I don't Cook lobster tails trigger.
Go to the fucking APP.
It tells you,
it tells you what to have,
what ingredients,
how to do it,
all of it on your phone.
It's a fucking incredible.
Yeah.
Let's get you in for the house.
I'll take it.
I have room.
Thank you sir.
So do you didn't get,
you didn't get an elk tag this year?
Oh Man.
Well I,
I have a,
I'm going with Chad Mendez,
a four rifle,
but where are you guys going?
Uh,
Colorado.
Oh,
I don't know exactly the area.
We're going to something set up through fins and feathers.
His companies as says,
as a guide service dude,
he's living the life man.
Is he like,
he even told after his last place,
like I'm not fighting the until next year.
You know,
it's hunting season my business.
Like,
yeah,
he loves it and he's,
he's awesome.
It was nice to see him come back and come back with a beautiful knockout.
Yeah.
I mean,
I still,
one of my very close friends and so we're doing a hunt here,
uh,
and end of October for rifle,
but my loves archery.
So yeah.
I didn't get an archery tag this year for,
for,
for an elk.
Can you hunt with your bow in,
um,
during rifle season?
I think you can.
Yeah.
Think about rifle season is though you're dealing with,
they're not run out and run.
Like right now.
We had a video of being up in Colorado,
like 20 yards from two big elk fighting.
They didn't even know,
like I was standing up,
or at least here we're standing up.
Didn't even know they were there,
you know,
just 20 yards away.
I mean,
that's why,
that's why you get to do,
uh,
archery during wet season,
you know?
Yeah.
Dude,
Amo just,
that's,
I live for it.
I love it so much.
It's to me,
it's like,
it makes me so happy that I have my meat for a year.
Yeah.
You know,
you shoot an elk,
basically.
I've have meat for you and for all my friends now,
I've gotten,
all my friends had like Brian Cowen and all these guys addicted to elk,
Tom Papa.
I give them pounds of it,
man.
Just constantly giving them elk sausage and elk steaks and it's like once you
taste that natural wild meat,
you go,
oh man.
Like just learning how much healthier it is for you to,
you know.
Do you feel different when you eat it?
I,
it's all I've ever eaten.
I grew up that way and so I,
I grew up hunting because my dad,
my dad's been an archery hunter has a wild man.
I met your dad.
Yeah,
he could tell right away.
Oh yeah.
I'm like,
okay.
That's where it,
that's where it all comes from.
My Dad.
Yeah.
He's,
I mean I remember that guy just,
I mean he's always been the bad state have ever known and he's always just,
he's game,
he's taking on crazy.
Huntsville will hike her ass off and go hike 20 miles and,
and work,
work really hard,
hunt public land.
Like it's never been the easy thing.
It's always been as hard as we can make it.
It's made me really like fall in love with hunting even more.
Those back country Huntsman people are starting to catch on to what an adventure
that is.
Yeah,
and you know these guys,
like my friend Aaron Schneider
who runs [inaudible],
one of the best backpack companies in the world,
they make a hunting backpacks and wilderness backpacks and it's like you used to
be able to go eight miles down the trail head and there'd be nobody.
He goes,
now you go there,
there's three tents because other guys are learning how to do this too,
and they're realizing this exp,
especially high country mule deer,
which is insanely difficult animal to hunt because there are so switched on
because every day they're running from mountain lions.
Every day is like that mountain lion.
Is that a mountain lion?
What was that branch?
So fucking smart you sketched out there,
so sketched out when you get to a five year old year,
which is what everybody wants to shoot,
well they want to shoot as a four five and older deer.
You're getting this giant deer.
They're probably 300 pounds.
They have enormous antlers.
I mean,
mule deer have these crazy rats all knotted up,
all knotted up crazy.
And they,
they've been hunted since day one.
Every day of their lives.
They've been five years.
It's like a fighter who's been fighting at a championship level five years.
Like you ain't getting away with no sloppy bullshit with him.
Exactly.
That's a good way to put it.
Perfect.
You can't snap on branches and they don't notice you're there.
They fucking term nocturnal as well.
Yeah.
Like I went up to five days before opening day and saw three,
two,
three pointers in a big four point right in the area.
I'm going to go hunt.
And then 10 days later I go out cause I missed opening day.
But uh,
I know 10 years ago after they're gone.
Yeah,
they are nocturnal.
They hide and they just realize that people are after them.
They,
they've,
they've been doing it so long that hunting season is literally like factored
into their internal clock DNA.
And they realize that they'll go,
oh well there's the people.
I know what this is.
Know they go,
Time to get the fuck out of here.
Oh eat at two 30 yeah,
they'll get it.
They'll just,
especially during full moons and things like that,
it's really interesting man.
It's once you experience these,
I mean even if you're not into hunting,
but if you do,
I always advise people just please just go hiking deep into the back country.
Just take,
take off six,
seven mile hike deep into the back country and it'll put it in perspective for
you.
Like those two and a half days I spent in Colorado,
I hiked probably 20 miles by myself with no one and I didn't get anything.
I didn't even see an animal.
I found one drop a horn,
Nova,
an elk.
I didn't see shit,
you know?
And I still loved it.
I still can't.
I was like,
I'm glad I did it.
You know,
hike my ass off was out there.
My cell phone didn't work.
It's just when you go out there,
do you bring a spotting scope?
Yeah.
So you bring a spotting scope.
Spotting scope by knows the whole range finder.
Yeah,
I know you looking at Google Earth in advance or I'm looking at,
Oh what's the APP?
Onyx hunt.
Yes.
He's Onyx Hunt.
Yeah.
So you kinda like downloads the area,
right?
So then when you showed your words public where you can even download the APP
too.
When you don't have service,
you can still use that.
It knows where you're at.
And you know like if you're on private property,
if you're on public land,
it like maps everything out for you that way.
So that thing,
that's an amazing APP.
But just being able to see the territory and know where the basins are and the
ridges are holes and get a sense like,
okay,
what time of year is it?
I mean it's,
it's,
there's,
it's not just going out to get,
there's a,
there's
really like a science to mule deer hunting and what the weather has been like.
And it's been hot.
They're going to be high country.
They're going to be really high if it's been hot.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
you want it to be like overcast and cool.
Silicon.
I'm wondering the day,
cause they'll bed down when it's hot.
They bed down all day long and that's why they come to nocturnal as well as the,
it's cool enough for them to expend energy to go get food to where if you go in
the middle of the day at 12 o'clock,
you,
you have to spot them with your by knows laying down and hopefully sneak up on
him and not let them see you or wait for them to get up and start feeding and
then sneak up on them.
Now when you go out there,
are you,
do you have the creeks mapped out or are you hauling in water?
What you,
how are you getting water?
Um,
I,
I'll always take those pills with me to build the purified water.
Purified the wire.
Dining tablets?
Yes.
Iodine tablets.
You're not supposed to drink too much of that though.
I'm sure you're not,
but I don't hunt.
Right.
24 seven.
You know what I mean?
Worst case scenario,
at least I'm not going to go out there and get Gerardia and get lost.
I can hardly seem to be the purify some water and I have a lighter,
well I don't have a,
I don't have,
I have a canteen so I would melt.
But anyways,
uh,
to heat it up,
yeah.
To build a heated up.
But yeah,
I know where the waterholes are.
I always know that and I bring enough water for me to drink and then I pack it
into camp too.
Um,
luckily this plot and Colorado wasn't very far from where I had to park my
truck,
so I was able to drive in a bunch of water.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah.
It's um,
but my dad though we hiked back in the room,
he's like 20 miles and then hunt back there.
Hopefully not finding anybody.
And like he said,
you still find people.
Um,
but yeah,
we have to bring the iodine pills or we have a pump and then we obviously we
packed in pots and we boil it and drink.
Usually we use,
usually we boil it back at camp,
but if you're out and about and you only have a canteen on it,
you'll fill it out,
throw it Ilm.
Peeling it and shake it around and 10 minutes later he got clean water.
Yeah.
You don't want any to beaver fever?
No.
Hell No.
Especially being at 20 months,
20 miles out bad,
that would suck.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's beautiful country though,
man.
I mean to,
to be able to go out there and to that back country,
Colorado,
Colorado where there's no,
people just realize it doesn't even look real.
It looks like,
you know,
find like a mountain lake up there.
They're like,
this isn't even real.
It's kind of a real estate.
Beautiful pictures you take.
Don't look like you.
Like you just come off the Internet.
Yeah.
That sounds near you,
man.
I mean,
sure
you picked,
I don't ever hunt though.
Yeah.
I need it to do you.
I'm sure I,
yeah,
I,
yeah.
I have asked him some of the stakes at the,
his house for the last camp actually,
so yeah,
we got this from the Kingston coffee.
Gary Mark also.
Yeah,
we have both.
Okay.
What kind of Diet do you fall?
I have actually when I'm out in California with him,
a Sam's family makes me the same meals.
Why not the same?
I don't know if the exact pretty much the same,
but the,
I eat the same meals as him and I usually eat pretty clean too.
When I did my hair analysis with the Sam,
my all my levels and stuff came back pretty good.
I was pretty pretty baseline or healthy for the most part.
Are you training or just training people?
Do you train yourself?
Train.
I stay sharp.
You know,
I've got to lead by example and,
and I love it.
So it's just what I've done since I was eight,
you know,
starting with the [inaudible] karate and just been on it since.
So then when he comes out the training lab and throws the gear and a holds Mitts
for me,
cub won like he just did like three hours of holding Mitts,
you know,
like he's getting a workout dude and that shit.
Just the impact and move it down.
Of course.
I don't just stand there either,
right guy.
I've got to give them the feel and the reactions and throwback and I get to play
UFC a little bit.
I thought getting beat up so it's fun to still again live vicariously through
these guys.
But uh,
I still definitely do train and again,
lead by example and stay sharp.
Have you ever thought about one day?
I mean you,
you're in a weird situation where you could potentially go to 45 and you could
potentially go to 25 when you could be champ,
champ,
champ.
My coach already.
Like when I first started working out with Sam and I was fighting go to the
first time,
he's like,
I'm gonna make you a three division champ.
It's like,
that's our goal.
Why don't you be the first one ever to do it?
He's always like reaching for the,
you know,
everything.
And the way I know I can do it too is because I can pack the weight on it with
him too.
I've gotten up to one 58 pretty solid before I went down to 35 is the first time
Max Holloway,
who is UFC 145 pound champion is a fucking big guy.
I don't think so big.
Eventually he's probably three a 50 fiver.
Yeah.
I don't know how he does it.
When,
when they had a medically stop him from cutting weight to make 55 when he's a 45
pound champion,
he started in around 85 pounds.
Oh,
Jesus.
How crazy is that?
He's big too,
man.
Big.
He's a big dude as well.
Yeah.
These 45 pounders,
right?
Yeah.
Look,
I wish there was a way to stop all this nonsense.
I wish everybody did it the way you're doing it,
where you're just a little bit overweight.
Yeah.
Have you ever been heavier before?
We had to cut [inaudible] never.
So it's always been your way?
Yeah.
And a good thing too is that I always train it the weight I'm going to be in the
night of my fight.
So if I went at one 35 so I'm going to be one 50 when I walk in the cage.
So I train at one 51 I'm going to fight 20 fives I'll probably walk in the cage
when like one 40 or low low forties I'm going to train at low forties you know,
and that's why my cancer longer I get in shape before I start my camp cause I
want to be,
I want to know exactly what that feeling is of what the night's going to be of
being in the cage.
And I want to be in shape.
Oh my weight to be where it's supposed to be.
And so it's like the same exact feeling from my whole camp.
It's got to be satisfying for you to have all these changes,
take all these chances,
go through all this emotional shit with leaving alpha male.
But the results prove themselves that you were making the right choices for your
career.
Very satisfying.
And I'm building my own,
my own everything,
you know,
um,
it's all kind of fighting in place in this because I've surrounded myself with
the right people.
I fall dewayne cause I believed in him.
I came back to southern California because I believe in Sam,
you know,
and there's guys like Steve Martin like I was talking about before that made
that possible,
you know,
and there's just like these,
for whatever reason,
this group of guys that I've just gotten around,
it's just a very synergistic and it works,
you know?
And so that's why I've been really focused on,
cause I've been to a lot of gyms that are money driven or ego driven and to make
sure that's not the case.
So you might be an awesome fighter,
but if you don't have the right mentality,
you're not part of the training lab,
you know,
um,
you might be the best fighter in the world,
but if you're a cancer,
we're not going to let you work out there and kind of really treating it like
we're professional athletes,
you know,
I mean we,
I am treated like we're professional athletes instead of before it was just a
fighter.
Well you,
have you seen that really across the board there's much more of an attitude of a
professional athlete versus just some bad ass guy who wants to fight and kick
ass and you're,
you're seeing people approach it much more scientifically now,
how much has that changed since you were on the ultimate fighter?
A lot.
When I first,
like I said,
when I first got an ultimate fighter,
I was a Alpha male and we sparred four or five days a week.
And was that 2012 1111 yeah,
2011 and then it can't air it,
I think 2012 so you think about that,
that's not that long ago.
We're talking about six,
seven years.
So in seven years the sports radically changed big time.
Wow.
I mean,
I mean it's also because of how big the and how mainstream the UFC is getting,
you know,
we're going to be on ESPN were on Fox.
We,
you know,
we went from spike,
like the more and more mainstream gives them more like legit,
it makes it in.
The more legitimate is the more science behind it.
The more that like why wouldn't guys that are smarter,
same Kalvia go for football because there's money and there's like exposure
behind it and we're going,
it was fighting,
it was so raw and just like whatever.
I feel like since it's so legitimized those smart trainers and now the guys that
we've been fighting forever are now coaches.
It just makes it more legit.
And you have more science and the ways to train behind it.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's really exciting.
I'm,
it's still growing and I feel like we're on the cutting edge of everything.
Um,
we don't,
we don't miss anything.
We don't miss anything.
Like we're in the,
this is by far of any place I've ever chained the most scientific and smart way
to train.
That's so exciting man.
Really is.
Tj has got a,
a bump in the marshaller evolutionary chain as far as how many people were
switching stances and having that fluid flow before TJ stepped in the kitchen.
Not that many.
Not that many at all.
Tom Switched his legs back and forth by the attacks.
Yeah,
it didn't,
he didn't fight the same way.
Right.
He as he did left you the way you do kind of like a,
you've seen it now in boxing too.
Like um,
it turns cough,
Terrence Crawford Hill,
he'll come out orthodox cause he's right handed.
But he's like,
I'm going to do better against this guy softball and in stay softball the rest
of the fight because he sees that advantage and being able to do that.
I mean boxers used say like never switched your stance.
Your defense won't be as good.
But now Marvin Hagler used to switch all the time.
You know,
here's one of the greatest of all time.
there's Orthodox,
the softball,
but then there's a whole world of things that you can do offensive and
defensively during the change of that stance as well.
That's people
over the edge here.
It's one thing to switch your stance to fight better that stance,
but then what about the strikes while switching your stance or in those crazy
emotions where I'm coming this way,
but you're over there.
I could fight.
It's almost like fighting two people at once,
Bill and create those angles and take advantage of them and they have to do this
slow to stay in
their stance kind of thing,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
there's,
there's fantastic event still stuck in a matrix
mapping out the killer shot him.
It may series and get a bunch of MMA flow drills
going to hell.
Yeah.
I'm really excited about the switch down to ESPN to you're really excited about
getting the UFC on ESPN.
I think it's a big deal,
man.
ESPN is such a huge venue for sports and there's so many like,
oh,
just hardcore sports fans.
You know when you think of sports,
it's ESPN shore and you think of like sports bars that have been fights on,
I mean if they have,
they're going to have ESPN on.
Yeah,
it's just this is,
I mean so many people just,
they just turn their TV on.
They put on ESPN and that's like all day long real sports fans.
They're going to get a chance to see guys like you,
you know,
real high level fighters and ESPN is also been putting on real world
championship boxing events,
which is very exciting there.
If they're going to do that and then they're gonna start putting on real high
level championship UFC fights as well,
people are going to get a chance to compare and contrast and see like,
wow,
I think it's going to open up a whole new world.
I think Fox was great and all the fuss,
but there's like,
what is it like 80 Fox sports channels and no one knows which one the fuck it's
on.
Yeah,
there are a lot of fucks channels.
Right.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I remember years ago when my,
uh,
Japan killin trips,
we went to a restaurant and they were showing some fights on TV and we lost her
shit with like all these shit,
the show and fights on TV,
Japan.
So cool.
Now it's out here all the time.
So,
you know,
thank you Dana White for Tito brothers,
the EOC for making it mainstream,
you know,
they're,
they and you as well,
Mr Ogun for having bringing martial arts to being so popular.
It is now.
It's like you guys have helped the evolution of martial arts come to come to
life and it's,
it's fun.
It is fun and it's,
you know,
people getting a chance to see where it's at right now,
which I don't think,
you know,
if someone hadn't seen a fight,
like your fight with Cody or your fight,
your first fight with Hanan Barao was a great example that your second fight was
really like a blowout.
I felt like in the sacrifice.
He just,
he knew you're going to fuck them up before the fight even started to evolve.
Yeah.
He didn't evolve.
Um,
but if you see these high level,
we know worldclass fights.
I think if people just got to look and what's what's going on right now at the
top level,
they'd get hooked,
you know,
real quick.
Well,
I mean you do a great job of um,
teaching people,
you know,
the commentators as well as people involved in journalists of MMA needed to
teach the average fan what to look for.
And I feel like he'd done a great job,
but if you've helped our sport grow because of that,
of not only hyping the fights up but making people knowledgeable of the MMA,
you know,
we need to teach the judges.
Yeah.
I haven't done the best job.
They're out there still.
I mean,
I just don't understand what commissions are waiting for.
I really don't.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't get,
what's the hold up?
Just these people were in competent.
Fire them,
get new people.
And it's not hard to do.
I don't believe it's hard to do.
I think,
I think a motivated person to fix the entire system inside of it.
You don't feel like they're worried about their job.
If the men get a bad decision,
like if I,
if I ruin your career,
if I still millions dollars out of your pocket,
what does it say?
Understand that aspect.
You know,
that they doing people's career.
I don't think they're just doing their job and they think they're insulated
trauma.
I don't have a job.
They have to be accountable because they still have a name,
you know their name gets,
you know,
you know Adelai bird scored the fight,
blah blah blah blah.
And you know,
you hear that.
So they're accountable somewhat.
And then people hear certain names and they're like,
oh not this fucking guy.
Cause you know that that guy's given some shitty ass decisions in the past,
but it's not enough.
And if you just left it off to,
if you ran it through a computer and looked at all the bad decisions and all
the,
the judges that call these bad decisions and rate them like an Uber driver,
he just get rid of them.
Just anyone who just gets a d or below,
just get rid of him.
You really know anyone who gets below in a,
you know,
I mean people are gonna make some questionable subjective decisions.
Some people like a submission game,
some people like a strike and game.
Some people big.
Some people think that guide takes you down no matter what he's on top of you
win.
Yes.
Well I feel like,
well they said it's going to not matter as much now,
but if you do,
if you didn't take down,
you have no damage.
Like take down.
Didn't even count.
Yeah.
Which I believe in because it's really who's winning the fight.
Not like the position we're in right then even me being a wrestler like yeah,
I can take people down just winning from being on top.
But that's not how any makes you be scored.
No,
I agree.
And I think that if a guy does some damage standing up and then you take them
down and hold him down for a full minute,
but nothing happens,
he did more damage standing up.
And there's a lot of judges to think that if you take someone down,
you're on top,
you win.
And they can't think that way.
It's just,
it's not wise,
especially when guys are battling off submissions off their back and,
or getting busted up with elbows from their back.
I mean there's just,
did you see Nico prices fight where he won from his back?
The,
with the foot and yeah.
Howard fished him that was hammered fists at him from that bottom,
knocked him out.
It was one of the crazies who,
who did he fight?
I don't remember who that was and I get excited.
So yeah,
fought off off his back one by hammer fist.
Okay.
It's like we're realizing there's,
you're not really safe.
And then there's,
there's things that people could figure out what to do and weird,
different places to find a way to be successful.
I just as much enthusiasm as you have about the sport and if you and myself and
a lot of other fans,
I want the judges to have that kind of enthusiasm as well.
Yeah.
I want them to go into these fights knowing what they're looking at.
So here it is right here.
Oh.
Like right before that does it show?
It looked really this oh wow.
From his back.
Hammer fist.
Some unconscious.
Wow.
Fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Never seen that before in my life.
I mean either.
And that's something that I don't know if he would see that in the curriculum or
not,
but well,
he's an opportunity in that position.
It's a good place to be.
When guys start seeing it happen,
they're going to go for it more.
Lauren,
you know,
you're going to see fighters go for that while the Travis Browne,
the elbow will honor from defending the takedown.
Travis started kaolin people.
He Kao Josh Barnett,
He Cha k
owed um,
uh,
Gabriel Gonzaga same way.
Yup.
He flatlines people from that position,
those long ass crazy.
It's an Alpha brain than I do.
What do you mean you're sharp?
You might have some stronger alphabet than the night job.
His job,
his job is to know this stuff there.
Your Alpha brain turbo that we're working.
Is it here now?
Uh,
no,
I have it at my house.
I said just a stronger version.
Yeah,
it's got some extra shit in it.
I'll worry about that a couple of years ago.
Yeah.
We keep,
our original Alpha brain was giving people headaches.
We had adjusted along the way.
Some people obviously the weaker
rigor you weren't made to take on the brain.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's a dose dependent thing and it's also,
there's people that get headaches and they drink caffeine and people that can't
drink milk.
You know,
there's a lot of bio biological variability,
but a,
what this is,
is a more potent version of Alpha and we're pushing the boundaries a little bit.
So we're going to run some tests on it.
And so we've got some trials and um,
I've been taking it and send me a couple,
I'll test it for you.
It works.
It's,
it's got some DMT.
It a little bit of Alpha brain.
You know what I really liked too,
and I've talked about this before,
is a neuro one.
It's a Bill Roman House keys company.
He's got a great nootropics supplement.
I'd like it to taste good too.
I drink the chocolate.
I feel like bill room,
we're asking you now the way I walk around with all my supplements and stuff,
he's got like a tackle box of them.
I do man.
Like when I travel now it's like I have a whole suitcase full of supplements.
It was like no matter where you go.
Yeah.
So even if you're on it like a couple of day road trip somewhere,
you bring in all your supplements with you though.
I have those divider packs.
You don't have to have like three of them.
Don't fuck around even though on a hunting trip.
Really?
Oh yeah man.
Wow.
Trippy.
Eat Clean.
Yeah,
I do Boston and those mountain house fucking fettuccine Alfredo drink go.
Let's freeze dried.
Like farts are so bad though.
But once you,
once you've been like so clean,
you know how it feels.
And then after your fight you eat like a fucking asshole for a week.
Yeah.
He ain't say,
he was like,
dude,
I gotta stop.
I gotta stop this shit.
Like I feel,
I feel depressed.
I feel horrible.
Like I gotta get back into eating clean.
You know,
it's like much time to just take her off after the Cody fight.
The second one,
a food nutrition wise,
probably like a week maybe.
Or maybe like when hot,
but even then it's just like,
not the whole day.
It's just like,
I'll have one bad meal and I'm like,
Oh fuck.
I shouldn't have done that.
Like I'm gonna feel that shit.
It like wanting a pizza,
cause you know you shouldn't have it.
Like looking at that pizza,
go fuck it.
We're going in.
Well now I never used to be a sweet tooth,
but now it's sugar.
It's desserts.
Like I used to be more just like a eat more pizza,
like stay,
whatever it could be.
But now since I haven't been eating sugar,
I want to drink a soda.
I want to don't know.
Regular Soda.
Yeah.
When I drink a regular soda,
the first thing I think,
I can't believe people drink this.
I don't like drinking this shit all day long cause I don't drink it.
So when I drink it my body's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Stupid.
Like I had a mountain dew after the fight I felt I felt like hung over the next
day.
It's weird at your tolerance drops too.
If you don't eat sugar anymore and then you take it in.
The first thing that happens to me like I'll have an ice cream Sundae.
I just have to sit down.
I'm like,
oh dude,
the sugars,
the root of all evil man.
It's so bad.
Body high doses.
Yeah.
Like you know people that walked around with a two liter Pepsi and just chug it
man.
I mean how many fucking servings are in a two liter Pepsi and some people will
drink that whole thing in a day.
Easy.
Thank you.
See the truck drivers on the [inaudible] on everyone just fill in their arteries
was black lacquer insights,
all that fat,
gut fat.
Just the lower abdominal fat pushes into your balls,
get another Pepsi.
Just so uncomfortable that they have like the Steven does.
Cvs Stone is those ones tastes good.
Those are all good.
ZV is are great.
I drink those all the time.
Feel free.
The difference between them and a diet coke in terms of flavor,
I actually liked them better.
When I drink diet coke.
Dot.
I'm like,
ah.
It's kind of fucking case chemicals.
Yeah.
Whereas via just tastes like a good flavor,
but it doesn't make you feel like shit.
You don't,
there's no glycaemic index.
There's no change in your sugar levels.
You just taste good.
It almost feels like there's no way it's,
there's no sugar in it.
No.
Yeah.
This stuff,
Stevia is an interesting thing because too much of it,
it tastes like shit.
It's kind of weird aftertaste,
right?
Yeah.
You gotta it's so potent.
You just need like a touch.
Yes,
but when you put it in your coffee,
like I'll put it in there like sugar,
but they are like,
whoa,
whoa.
Nope.
It's rough.
Different.
What other stuff does he have you eating that you weren't eating before?
Was there any like concentration on like different kinds of greens or w I juice
like crazy now and you're juicing mostly green stuff.
A lot of it,
I mean there's this,
um,
do you blend or you know,
I juice,
I do masticating juicer a cold press juicer.
You gotta.
Cause if it's something fast,
like a blender,
it kills a lot of the nutrients and you absorb more of that.
So even if you were just the eat this giant table of raw food,
you would absorb less of it than if you juiced it.
Really?
Why is that?
Because it goes right in your bloodstream.
It's something about how your body breaks it down.
Yeah.
So something about the cold press juice is,
is your body's absorbing it more.
So,
I mean that's,
that's like,
uh,
a half to even when I'm traveling and how my juicer,
I ended up buying them,
which aren't as good,
but I have to drink some sort of green juice every day.
And Are you taking it with any kind of fat?
Because what I heard about,
especially with vegetable juice,
that your body absorbs it better with fat,
like with coconut oil or avocado oil or something like that.
Yeah,
we do that.
We do a,
yes,
we have to do a certain certain kinds of MCT oil.
Um,
I take,
uh,
of tablespoons in the day and then an eye to help absorb not only that,
but then the ubiquinol goes with it helped me like rebuild red blood cells and
do a bunch of,
what does ubiquinol it's also some sort of oil.
I take them in a pill,
but some sort of like a oil that helps with the transport chain of,
I couldn't
even tell you I get salmon.
He'd be,
he'd probably try to hold back point to get him in here.
Dude.
He'd be very interesting.
But a,
I almost don't want you to,
cause that's where all my secrets on.
There's people that just wouldn't listen anyway.
Yeah,
that's true.
Because so many people that would then they would listen and they wouldn't
really follow it.
But it's a full time fucking job though.
You know what I mean?
Like you can't be lazy and do to do Sam Shit.
Like I can't imagine how you could be,
it seems like you have to be on top of it all the time.
I don't have time in the day to do all this shit that he hasn't been doing it as
well as training.
So do you take the MCT oil with the green shoes?
Oh you can or just take it and for people don't know what that is.
A medium change.
Triglyceride oil is derived from coconut oil,
so it's a the more nutritious form of coconut oil so you can take it.
But what it was explained to me was that you're better off when you're taking
something that's as nutrient dense as juice,
cold press juice,
that you really should take it with a fat and then it'll help your body absorb
the nutrients better.
And I don't know,
he never told us that.
Okay,
but maybe I'm wrong and I don't know.
I mean he didn't matter.
No,
he doesn't know everything.
What I know.
But take Kale shakes.
I always add either coconut oil or why I usually at both coconut oil and MCT oil
to it.
I mean,
I think that's not bad for you.
So why not?
You know,
I don't know if it's better or not,
but I know it's not bad for you.
Yeah.
Now,
um,
what is your ratio like fats to protein?
Do you know what that is or does heat map all that stuff,
apps,
all of that out and depending where I'm at and how my body is recovering,
um,
but yeah,
I'm high,
high fat,
high protein diet,
you know,
um,
low to no carb.
Obviously different kinds of carbs.
I have to have carbs,
but just like I won't be Ketogenic,
but I would get my body into ketosis certain times throughout my camp.
Make me insulin like,
um,
sensitivity high.
Right?
Um,
so I'll eat like simple carbs or breakdown faster.
You know,
they've found that people even on this carnivore diet,
which a lot of people are doing now,
they still reach ketosis.
It's still reached ketosis because they're not taking any grain and not taking
it any carbohydrates.
And even though your body converts protein through Glucogenesis,
they couldn't converts it into sugars and to glucose.
Um,
it's,
it,
it's doing it in a very efficient way and processing in a way that a lot of
these people are in Ketosis all the day.
Most of the time just not,
not the same like high levels.
If you were going like a regular ketogenic diet,
I think it's supposed to be 70% fat,
something crazy or 60 something percent fat and then the rest protein.
Did you tell Jordan Peterson that isn't eating all meat?
Yeah,
hygiene.
Amit.
I don't,
I think,
and I had his daughter on recently as well and it's very controversial,
uh,
particularly for his daughter because his daughter was giving paid nutritional
consult consultation,
which doesn't really have a background in nutrition,
but she's just showing people what really has worked for her and her,
her experience and her background.
I think her and her father Jordan,
I think he has a serious autoimmune issue,
like serious.
And I think it's very possible that there are some people amongst us that are
allergic to almost everything.
Wow.
They have allergic reactions to all kinds of different foods.
I think it's really,
really rare.
I think for most people like you or I,
you're really better off eating rich,
dark green leafy vegetables and nuts and,
and fish and chicken and wild game and uh,
you know,
I think if you get some wild Turkey or some,
wild pheasants and just,
you should eat really good,
lean,
healthy,
real food.
I think most people can eat apples and oranges and watermelon and there's no
problem.
But I think there are a few people amongst us and I think Jordan's one of them
where his body just fucking rejects things.
I think he gets,
his body has terrible reactions to all these different things and going on an
all meat diet is cured.
His depression got him.
I'll find antidepressants for the first time in more than two decades.
Oh Wow.
It reduced his weight back to the weight it was when he was 25 years old.
I just don't think it's a viable or intelligent diet for everyone in mass as,
yeah.
Yeah.
I just think it's,
it's a good diet for people that are very extreme in their nutrition
requirements because they have some serious autoimmune issues.
If you have autoimmune issues,
you should definitely go towards Quito.
Yeah.
You know,
a Sam's gotten rid of my psoriasis.
I didn't even know you could get rid of it,
but got rid of my psoriasis with my diet.
I mean they say it could be from the stem cells too,
but I believe it's from,
I mean,
I did so much stuff,
but,
um,
the Diet,
you know,
well,
I know several people that have got rid of their psoriasis through that.
I think Jordan is actually one of them as well.
He had psoriasis,
the psoriasis.
He also had some serious gum disease that he was having for his whole life.
Gone as soon as he got in his carnivore diet.
And it's just,
I mean,
he's,
he just eating beef.
That's it.
I mean,
literally he drinks for drinks,
water and eats beef.
That is it bad for your,
like you would think so how Brock Lesnar got hurt,
right?
He doesn't say years.
Brock got diverticulitis.
Uh,
Anthony Bordain told me that sometimes people get diverticulitis from all sorts
of reasons.
From like eating.
You could have a seed,
like a fucking some seed from some plant.
The UAE,
it gets stuck somewhere in your lining.
It gets infected and you get diverticulitis from that.
He said,
diverticulitis can come from a lot of different things.
I think Brock probably wasn't even chewing.
I think he was probably swallowing animals out in the wild,
uh,
grabbing good fucking gophers and shit and just shut down,
screaming naked on the top of it.
Oh yeah,
that's sick.
Fuck.
I'm really bummed out that the WWE,
um,
ever had him.
I really feel like if Brock Lesnar had just gone from amateur wrestling,
dude,
he was a beast.
He's a beast.
And if he just completely dedicated himself to mixed martial arts from the jump,
I mean,
he's already looking,
knocked out.
Randy coture,
he battered Frank Mir.
I mean,
he submitted Shane Carwyn.
He already has an incredible resume for a guy that was a WWE star,
a multimillionaire star before he
ever fought his first MMA fight.
Just such a savage.
It was just beating inside of his heart so bad that he wanted to do it but came
in and did it.
Really did it last to cane lost a fucking Overeem.
I mean beat Mark Hunt.
Even though Mark Kahn says he was cheating it seems it might have been correct.
You know,
mark on went on a rant today about,
uh,
about Brock Lesnar.
Oh really?
I call them a cheat and piece of shit is mad that he's coming back to the UFC.
He's got,
he's got like a legit claim.
Yeah,
for sure he does.
I mean Brock's only fought the top of the top.
He's never fought like a warmup fight.
He's never came in and had a warmup fight.
You know,
I don't watch WWE,
but they say shrinking.
Oh yeah,
you saw it.
I was about to come in.
They're already,
is there a testing pool?
They're gonna be knocking on your door.
We already is.
That's what he's getting smaller.
They're knocking on your door.
Six o'clock in the morning.
Cause the problem when he fought hunt right here,
there was some stuff going to be tested or something.
Yeah,
there was some weird loophole.
Well,
so he retired and when you come back you're supposed to be go through like a
four month testing before we even allowed to accept a fight and they waive that
for month of testing and they just started like,
so he was getting tested once he came back.
But he didn't have to have that four month of testing without having a fight.
This is what I heard.
And you Sata.
Yup.
Well you saw it.
It's changed the game.
Kids change the game
and I look better than I did back then.
Jack City right now I'm better.
I'm looking better.
Like it's awesome man.
I'm,
I'm the,
the professionalism and that's going around like a brown spots.
Just,
it's just made me continue.
I mean I've always been hungry but uh,
just like the science behind it and maybe all to go three different weight
classes and being real and just me being the baddest man on the planet has got
me like ready to go.
You know,
like that's the only photos they have before and after I find a better one.
I'll try that.
Pull that one up again.
I didn't see much difference there.
Anybody pull that up,
Jamie?
Anybody who stands or sits the way Brock is sitting on the one on the right
here,
the his arms are spread wide no matter what.
He's going to be big.
Yeah,
he's still going to be 265 fucking pounds.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well there you kind of get it.
Yeah.
He's,
he's losing some size definitely,
but he's going to keep a lot.
He's definitely gonna lose a lot.
The thing that's going to fuck with his head,
if anything,
does,
is when you are on steroids for a long time or anything,
that jacks up your endocrine system the way worth.
We're assuming he did your,
when it's so
this is so,
he's already gotten caught trying to talk to your lawyer,
sorry.
Oh,
you're assuming he did.
His endocrine system's gotta be struggling and he's 40 years old now.
I mean it's,
it's only 40 yeah.
Nothing.
He must not even be 40 he might be 39 how old is Brock Lesnar?
But he's 49 or 39 and Viking years.
The age.
Yeah.
What
do you want?
41 41.
Yeah,
close enough.
He's got to get in now.
Why can,
yeah.
Heck yeah.
So what do you think you did that elevated your testosterone?
I think,
um,
my recovery,
so not red lining my body all the freaking time I try.
I tried too hard.
Like I always went to hard.
I always wanted to do more.
I'm an oldest school wrestler.
Like more is better.
More is better.
Trained trainer.
No.
So my recovery big time listening to my body and this and that.
So by your heart rate variability,
when you're sleeping,
it'll tell you when you wake up,
how recovered you are and how hard you push it that day.
So being the CEO of Tj Dillashaw and deciding,
say if I,
even if it's on the schedule,
I'm going to go hard the next day,
but I wake up,
not recovered.
Call everyone like,
hey man,
I'm not coming in today.
I got to go walk around with the family.
I'm not training.
Taking it off so that you know by how many heartbeats difference.
Like,
it's not,
it's not the heartbeat.
It's how variability,
the variability.
So sometimes your heart,
your heart shouldn't just be everyone's every second.
It should be like 0.8,
1.4 seconds.
Like we're like all like,
like,
um,
so you're,
it'll tell you that your central nervous system,
it is not worn out.
So when you're getting sick or you're overworked,
you're body will tell you from your heart rate that that is about to happen,
you know?
So if you can catch it and if you don't listen to it and you just keep going,
like you go down this deep hole that you'll never come out of,
you know,
but if you'd catch it right away,
no matter what,
your body's always going to do peaks and valleys.
But you want your valley to be lower in your piece to keep getting higher value
low,
keep getting higher.
And the way to do that as through your recovery,
which is gonna help your testosterone production and your growth hormone
production when you're sleeping,
as well as my segmentation,
um,
what Immunos I'm taking and why and when I'm taking them.
Um,
you know,
the Arginine,
the 21,
blended Aminos like,
oh,
I'll take them all different times.
Um,
when did take them a usually three times a day.
sometimes I'll,
I'll take certain things at nights and things in the morning depending on what
it's supposed to do for me.
Like my,
my,
um,
ornithine my glycine and my trip to fan.
I take at night for,
I go to bed because it was helping my,
it just all show my growth hormone boost.
Um,
things will take during the day because it's better for my energy system,
ITB,
production.
Um,
uh,
yeah.
So he's just got all this mapped out for you.
The man.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
He's,
how many people could he possibly do that for though?
He would have to teach at the coaches to do it.
You know,
he'd have to be like a mentor ship or coaches would come in and they would train
on or anything,
you know,
and then hopefully stay with us.
Yes.
That's the thing.
Like if you teach someone too much,
they can go do whatever they want and they can have this,
the science.
Eventually it will get out to where you know you're going to see the test,
you know what you're going to see what he's doing and people are going to want
to come and learn how to do it.
And for heart rate,
very,
very ability.
Do you sleep with a chest strap and a wrist watch that the registers are,
they don't have to have the wristwatch on,
but as long as it's close enough to register your heartstrings,
what are you using?
Which,
which one?
Um,
you seem tone or was it Suunto so I'm done.
Santo.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's a,
they make hunting watches as well.
They make awesome honey watch is the best.
Yeah.
Like gps trackers,
everything.
I use one of those.
Yeah,
those are,
and then so what do you do?
Do you take the data from that and you put it on a PC?
Like he's got an algorithm?
Um,
it's why,
yeah,
it went from that.
I can say my washing is connected to my phone.
Okay.
And then Sam is logged in to watch is physically connected to your phone or
through an APP?
Through Bluetooth's snap.
Yeah.
So,
the um,
so the APP shows you yeah,
the APP I can put in my information and it sends it straight to Sam's computer.
So every morning he checks in the morning,
he logs in and gets your data mine,
he's got a list of people that he checks,
you know,
and depending on where they're at right now,
I'm not doing it.
Obviously I don't need to just track my recovery.
But when I'm in camp,
he's tracking my recovery and he'll let me in the know in the morning,
like,
look man,
you're 84% recovered this,
pick it up or you're 20%,
you need to chill.
You know,
and like you'll decide,
so my,
my,
my week to week,
you have an idea what is going to be,
but it always changes.
How many times do you think on these days where you looked at the results and
said,
okay,
I'm taking the day off.
Would you have just said,
don't be a pussy and push through this shit?
Oh yeah,
I would have easily,
I mean,
I don't feel that bad,
but then the next,
my next training practice like,
damn,
I fucking feel good.
I'm primed,
ready to go.
You know?
And so is it hard to do that to let us take your foot off the gas?
I,
I've always,
even in the past when I've read a lot of my body and didn't know the science had
been had to pull back,
but now that I know it,
it's,
it makes it easier for me to do it,
but it's still very hard.
It's still very hard to not do more,
not do more.
Yeah.
But Dad's taught me work your fucking ass off.
Working hard,
work hard.
Work harder than the next guy,
you know?
But work hard when you work in,
but no one did not work.
Yes.
I think that applies to life too.
I really do.
I think you could just burn it out all the time.
Just like I was saying,
if like it was your sole focus was fighting,
I would burn myself out.
I have to have these escapes.
I have to be able to do other things out to enjoy family time.
I have to go golfing,
I have to go hunting,
I have to get on the lake.
And even during fight camp,
so I have,
I used to be like fight camp was fight camp.
That's all I did.
Right.
But now going with Sam and having these days off,
I get to spend more family time.
I get to actually do shit.
I like on certain days,
like I have two days off a week and we spread them out at different times.
Sometimes I might have three centers that might have more to me if from getting
sick or if I'm overworked.
But um,
I guess you get to go do shit.
I get to go wake board,
you know.
That's nice.
Yeah.
Now,
um,
is there anything else that he's got you doing?
It's weird that we haven't,
like you doing any east him,
are you doing anything?
I mean it's always changing.
We're getting really big into like the extra um,
recovery stuff.
The cryo is the,
um,
the light therapy,
the [inaudible] machines,
the,
oh,
excuse me,
hyperbaric chambers.
Um,
when to do them and how to,
how to test everything.
Everyone has always known that are good for you,
but I don't feel like there's been the exact numbers behind it and now he's
going to track it kind of thing.
So we're getting more into that realm of it.
Um,
I use an alto lab that helps with me getting my hypoxic state to do altitude
training,
um,
to where I'm breathing in that for an hour a day.
Uh,
and that's,
you know,
I'm going anywhere to like 40,000 feet,
but there's only like certain like blanks you could do it for.
Then you have to take,
like for instance,
like doing like six minutes on,
five minutes off or three minutes on three,
like in,
in tracking what my body's doing the next day.
Um,
what else we're doing.
Obviously my diet supplementation we talked about,
I mean,
just a crazy workout stuff he's got us doing too,
you know?
Um,
like I said,
it's kind of like rocky training.
Um,
but it's a shit ton of core work and his warmup is not a warm of his warm of is
usually everyone else's workout.
He's pushing us to our lactate threshold to where like you want to throw up,
you're done.
And then we're doing muscular endurance,
you know,
so we're not doing any kind of strengthening and I've pushed that limit so maybe
I've hit hard ground and pound.
You know when you stand up and you have muscle pump and you can't go,
you don't have that anymore because you're used to,
your lactate threshold is higher now.
So Ah,
if my lactate there,
she's the oldest higher than,
I'm not going to be able to push myself to where I have that,
that pump,
you know?
And so get to that point so you know what it feels like.
Right.
So mentally,
if I ever get to that point in a fight,
I'll know cake cause I've been there as well as when you get there and you work
out past it s a smart way,
then it's going to increase your lactate threshold and you're like,
it'll take you longer to get to that point.
So when you're doing strength and conditioning work,
you're,
you're exhausting yourself before you're doing strength work.
Not always,
but yes.
Yeah.
So some workouts aren't as hard as others,
but yeah,
the ones that were like when I said the hardest I've ever worked on my entire
life was that kind of shit.
Wow.
Yeah.
To where you think like even especially like when I first started doing it,
but all right,
nice.
A good workout.
You good job.
All right,
one more silver.
Let's hit that was hit the garage.
We're lifting,
you know,
or we're hitting the pool.
We're swimming.
So yeah,
to him he's reason tough dude.
But now my girl does called me.
I needed to go with coach Sam
saying your Yak,
I know it was,
I know a stringy fishing day and I always pull up and like I see the stop sign
right before I turned left to get to his house.
I'm like fuck,
I could just keep going.
I don't have to turn left.
I don't have to.
But if you're in the garage and you continue to come back,
you're a Sicko.
You like this shit.
Now,
how do you organize that strength and conditioning days and what precedent?
Like how,
what importance is strength and conditioning takeover skill work.
Like how do you organize that?
That's something that I still is always going have to be developed depending on
person to person who needs more skill.
Right.
And who's obviously you never have it completely,
but um,
some people will need more skill training than others.
And if you're getting in there,
like when I first started him in May,
I probably should've done string conditioning for a year and a half.
I should only done skill cause I needed to catch up.
Um,
but I'm to the point now where each camp changes with technique and I've seen
going to continue to grow and that's why my camps are so long.
I called do more skill outside of camp time and more getting my body ready.
I don't know if I'm answering your question,
but when you are,
um,
it's just,
it always changes.
You don't want to burn yourself out that hard and then spar,
that's still something that I feel like we're even even learning with Sam still
too.
Like he always,
he's a wrestler and he knows training and he knows strength conditioning and
that's,
we listen to our heart rate and that's why every coach is,
and that's the thing too,
is it at our team,
every coach is going to talk to each other.
They're all on the same page.
We know like they know what days are going to be off.
Like no one's going to show up to the gym day.
If they do,
we're going to go light because we pushed it yesterday.
It's never going to be like distinguishing coach's job is to kill you now.
You're going to,
in wrestling,
he's going to kill you too.
Like we're all on the same schedule so that we know that may when days are our
active recovery.
So if you're going to go into practice,
you're just drilling,
you're moving light,
you're not going hard cause you got killed the day before.
So when you're at your peak is hardest days,
your next day's either off or uh,
an active rest day.
Do Yoga,
go do some yoga,
get your mind off it,
you know.
And does he have your weeks planned out in advance or does he doing it day to
day or how was he when,
when do you know what you're going to be doing?
Um,
I don't know,
but he,
you know,
he plans out everything in advance and I'll be the whole camp my whole life.
I have camp does it dude?
He's like my life coach man.
Like even after this fight is like,
all right,
it was not changing the Diet.
I don't want just rice is coming back.
I don't want to have to work from ground zero.
I want to like stay this,
we can keep building.
Um,
so he's like my life coach and all like,
I feel like I'm cheating on him when I'm eating a cheeseburger with Don's on it,
you know?
But it's funny,
he's got the whole camp planned out.
My whole continuing to grow and obviously it will vary depending on my recovery.
Now with this ESPN deal,
I know they're planning on some pretty big events.
Right.
Did they,
have they talked to you about finding on ESPN?
Not yet.
No.
I mean,
obviously being a champion want to be pay per view though.
Yeah,
right.
That's where the kids ashes at.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's where it comes down to you actually,
you're,
you're betting on yourself.
You know,
when you're fight live TV,
it's,
you get a lot of viewers,
you build your name right.
But when you have these paper views,
you're,
you're betting on that.
People want to watch you because you're,
you,
you know,
and uh,
I've just continued to fight my fucking ass off and go ham,
you know,
I was going to be my style.
I'm always going to go pedal to the metal when I fight looking for knockouts
because that's my entertaining.
That's how I'm entertaining.
Like,
yeah,
sure.
I'll maybe talk confidence and talk trash.
I'm gonna fuck you up,
you know,
but I'm not going to go out and be the,
the um,
Colbys you know,
I'm not going to go crazy because my personality,
I want to be able to,
I mean,
I know it's fun.
It's awesome.
We like those guys,
but I want to be,
to look back on my career and like show my kid like,
look,
that's who I was.
Like,
I fucking stay myself.
I stay much true color.
I'm an open fucking book.
I tell them whatever it is,
you know,
but I want it to be like the chocolate l days.
You step out there and fucking knock someone out.
You get love for it.
You know,
like the real kind of gladiator shit.
Well,
it's definitely building for you now,
you know,
I mean there was a lot of negative energy that was coming your way when you left
Alpha male and when you are on the ultimate fighter,
there was some negative shit that was coming your way.
But it seems like with every victory,
like all that stuff's going behind you and now,
now it's really obvious you made the right choice and Cody out twice in a row.
Yeah,
I didn't want to do the ultimate fighter.
They asked me,
he's like,
Hey,
oh.
So I was like,
I want my fucking title fight.
Like I'm going to need it for a while.
You know,
I've been begging for it and then obviously they're going to give me Cody,
but like,
hey,
we want you to coach Holtmann fighter.
I was like,
fuck,
of course I got to go.
Coach gets Alpha male.
It's like the last thing I want to do.
I knew all this shit was going to be fucking crazy.
Um,
and so I didn't want to do it,
but I wasn't going to say no because that's my thing.
I shot at the title,
you know,
and uh,
I'm fucking so glad I did it cause I got to show my true colors.
I get to show how much I care about this war,
how much I got to be a martial artist,
teach the way that me and Dwayne kind of do things very professional.
Um,
let them be fucking assholes and then come around and have it bite him in the
ass,
you know,
like it,
it worked out perfect for me because we got to show it really is,
is what,
sorry.
No,
go for it.
It was a good opportunity to,
it was a good opportunity to showcase how to handle those situations.
You get to be your own judge.
The more evidence you have in front of you,
you get to be your own judge of what actually happened rather than Uriah and
Cody running their fucking mouth of,
of me leaving,
me being a trader,
me doing this,
me taking PDDs compared to what's actually going down.
You know what I mean?
Like you get to be the judge yourself on who I am,
you know?
So the more you get to know,
I mean that's why she'll look at the more you get to find out about me,
the more you get to know me.
Did you and Cody talk after the fight at all?
No.
I mean I shouldn't show respect to them and like I never had a problem with Cody
when we were at [inaudible].
I felt like I kind of feel bad for the guy because this wasn't any of his drama.
You know,
like he was coming to the team when I was kind of on my way out.
he just started,
I was holding it for him.
He just got into the UFC cause we didn't have a coach because Dwayne left.
Right.
So I'm,
I'm running the kickboxing classes.
Dwayne left,
I'm the only one left there to coach practices I'm holding mitts from and stuff
like that.
Um,
and then I get the ultimatum and I leave and then he becomes champion.
Now it's like all this pressure from Uriah team,
Alpha male to talk shit and us be the rivals.
Him was weighed on his shoulders.
I mean,
that fucking sucks.
I feel like that's a big flag to have to carry rather than just carry your own
flag.
Carrie,
what you care about?
Carry your own fucking flag instead of like,
damn,
I got all my team that are all my back.
Like that's a lot of pressure,
you know?
Yeah.
I think for him he really felt like that team and that family environment is
what he needed.
That it really,
you mean he said Alpha male saved his life.
It meant a lot to him.
Yeah.
He should have thought that martial arts saved your life.
You know what I mean?
Like yeah,
the team,
it's,
it's awesome having a team is having it.
Like even like we have a team now I say be individualized,
but it's really good to have a team because you guys are going through the same
shit together.
It's good to have friends that are doing the same shit.
Like I can't only have average Joe friends because they don't know what it is to
be me.
They don't know what,
what should I have to do to be the world champion.
So it's good to have those guys around you.
Um,
but really you got to know that martial arts is what's going to steer you in the
right direction.
If I wouldn't had wrestling,
if I wonder,
went to college with wrestling,
I would've fucking fuck shit up.
You know?
I just had that personality.
Like I'm really glad that wrestling kept me grounded and then getting into
martial arts and I'm a very addictive person.
I mean,
who knows what I'd be addicted to if it wasn't martial arts.
I'm exactly the same way.
At least I,
I found the right things to be addicted to.
I think that's important for so many kids.
I think there's so many young kids that are growing up and they have all this
anxious and you know,
they're,
they just,
their bodies are anxious and they're filled with fucking testosterone and they
just,
yeah,
the kids want to break things.
I think if you could focus that into wrestling or giving them Rhydlin yeah,
let him wrestle.
Just any kind of martial arts,
Jujitsu,
something.
It's just so good for their self esteem and for this d relieving that excess
energy allows them to see more clearly think things through better.
It's just so good for them.
And unfortunately you're seeing less and less of that with people today.
There's less and less martial arts and people's lives.
So I make a bunch of free videos and just lead by example.
You know,
like you asked me if I still train.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
I do like I love this.
And,
and again,
bunch of free video seminar can find,
you can find march,
like it's easier to access of martial arts right now.
Like Dwayne's Dwayne's online academy for instance.
Like you can get technique 24,
seven,
go do it in your garage with your buddy.
You don't hit a punching bag,
right.
Learn Jujitsu online.
Like,
you know,
I'm starting not even like the physical fitness part of training and I'm
starting my own,
um,
my own academy as well.
Online trauma to teaching not only the techniques behind it,
but how I get stronger at doing them,
how I get in better shape,
like a physical fitness part of it as well.
And is not going to be available.
Uh,
probably s less than a month,
hopefully.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Hell yeah man.
Beautiful.
It'll be,
I mean,
you can get more information on it now just on Tj dillashaw.com.
Um,
but yeah,
I'm going to start an online kind of,
I'm actually meeting Dwayne,
not only coach me in the technique of martial arts,
but you know,
the way he's organized everything,
how he's learned from boss,
how to organize,
how to create a system.
I've kind of done the same thing,
you know.
Um,
I've,
I've not only widget the technique,
but the lifestyle,
you know,
it's,
I'm kind of running with that and running with that and I want to show me,
I'm not going to,
because eventually I'm not going to hold back and have any secrets.
I'm going to tell everyone everything you know,
and I want to start a champ camp.
I want to do like a very exclusive champ camp where it's like only 10 people can
come and you come and stay with me,
live at my house in Colorado,
go wakeboarding.
But then we also learned like the mental aspect of how I be,
how I think to be a champion,
how I eat,
how the techniques taking him to doing shim like and I want to cause like so we
need to do is lead by example,
right?
Help out because then I can really feel like I can like let loose.
I can tell you everything to where like I don't want to sit to tell everyone
everything cause I'm giving away my secrets.
That's who I am.
That's why I'm the best in the world.
But I loved to teach and I love to do it and I feel like by giving them small
like small groups and give him some intimate time,
doing a real champ camp is something I want to do as well.
And I want to start creating as an art critic and places where we can have some
fun too.
Cause I think fighting,
you got to have fun in this thing.
Like you were talking to Donald Serone,
uh,
not too long ago and that guy has to have fun.
If he's too much into the,
like the professionals of I'm just fighting,
then he's going to fall apart,
you know?
Um,
and so I want to teach you that I do that shit or my recovery serious like my
nutrition serious,
like teach you how I read everything.
No secrets,
you know.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Well listen man,
this sport is exploding and one of the reasons why it's exploding,
the
guys at the very top like you that are constantly innovating and keeping an open
mind and constantly improving.
You're a
big part of the whole grocery list thing,
man.
It's awesome.
It's awesome to see.
So congratulations to you sir.
Congratulations.
A master splitting.
Yeah,
you guys are awesome man.
Big Fan of both.
You keep kicking ass.
Oh,
please tell people where you're academy is in column a Westminster Hunter at the
Wadsworth.
And we have a super seminar coming up with Sensei boss and Trevor Whitman and Tj
Dillashaw October 27th.
And then we've got the killer shot MMA series coming out as well.
Your website is a bang,
moitai.com and oh yeah.
And TJ Dillashaw on Instagram,
Twitter,
every,
all he just needed a little shot.
No nicknames,
no nothing.
Beautiful.
[inaudible] the heck.
Yeah,
man.
Thank you,
gentlemen.
Drogon
okay.